[Laughter]
[Music]
of course come bearing gifts to two new
texans so that's that's a separate thing
um but i i did i was at the range
working and i was wearing a hawaiian
shirt
it wasn't even a hawaiian shirt i bought
it in czech republic and uh but it
looked like hawaiian shirt
and in the comment section i was in body
armor i had my gun i was literally
working
everybody was like oh my gosh you're
wearing a hawaiian shirt oh you're part
of this
super extremist like white supremist
group and i was like what i'm wearing a
hawaiian shirt
and they start like freaking out like
cancer culture and i was like i bought
that
it doesn't matter where i bought it but
now because you're telling me i'm not
supposed to wear it because i guess wine
shirts are
for a uniform for white supremacists oh
god please google this this is a new
thing
yeah what yep hawaiian shirts or white
supremacists do it so
of course the first thing i did was like
buy every hawaiian shirt i can possibly
find just because i'm not supposed to
you know who the [ __ ] is saying this i
need to see this
that is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard how could a hawaiian
shirt be white supremacist i don't think
there's any logic ever attached to any
of these things
no but um like the boot i think like the
boogaloo
bros so that's what the wall street
journal says why the extremist
boogaloo boys wear hawaiian shirts
please put that up on the screen
i need to see this [ __ ] nonsense oh
my god this is real
why the extremists boogaloo boys oh my
god
aloha shirts have become a disconcerting
signature
for members of a gun-toting
anti-government what does it say
you made it a little too big i work for
the government so faction does it does
that
cancel this oh my god in the past couple
weeks following the killing of george
floyd
curiously dressed counter protesters
have attended scattered demonstrations
across the u.s armed and disconcertingly
garbed in magnum p.i style floral
hawaiian shirts
magna pie is pretty [ __ ] american
yeah it's pretty epic three things here
they're really comfortable floral is a
great pattern
and they're very breathable and you can
and on the range i like to do the top
button thing and pop a collar so you
don't get hot brass down your neck
because when we're shooting a ton
so it's like a don't get burned don't
want to be a redneck you know yeah
like i hate white supremists but what's
wrong with hawaiian shirts
we can't let them take away hawaiians no
that's the exact point that i'm
trying to i was like you tell me the
things that i'm not supposed to do
and i'm going to do those things because
i'm not going to let you take those
things from me there they are far right
boogaloo movement is using hawaiian
churches that's a chubby shirt
the dude right there on the far right i
have that shirt
oh they're wearing the shirts to hide
their intentions
what no they wear them because they're
comfortable
and they're breathable and they're and
this one's stretchy they're taking away
everything fun
you can't even do okay anymore remember
okay is now i still do that
i do too um it's been around way too
long you can't steal
scuba diving skydiving military like you
like i can't
i don't know what the other symbol is
for not okay there's some things that
it's like gay people took over the
rainbow
okay you could have the rainbow i don't
know i like my son really likes a
rainbow i like rainbows
i don't i'll still wear a rainbow i
don't give a [ __ ] for sure but i do
recognize that it's
i mean at least they have partial
ownership of it
yeah but like the okay sign um you know
you can use the emojis to text people
yeah and i
cannot help but use the okay sign for
still on the emojis yeah it is
for any positive response controversial
it's not what about thumbs up when's
that going to be bad yeah
pretty soon it has to be [ __ ] stupid
it isn't some other country correct
thumbs up is yeah when i was young they
always taught us like
middle finger means something in america
but in like some other country it
doesn't but like thumbs up in some
countries real bad
sort of like [ __ ] in english like the
italians like do the ch the chin thing
yeah it's like symbols in different
countries mean different things oh okay
um i don't know how bad it really mean
you know if they're really going to
get pissed but i've heard that
this find out where the thumbs up is bad
i'm never going there
get the thumbs up yeah i want to find
out we're
saying okay is bad and then oh dang it
we're already here
most of those started off with 4chan
just [ __ ] around 4chan was just
pretending
in iran greece russia sardinia and parts
of west africa
the thumbs up is as rude as the middle
finger is in the uk
so no posing in front of the parthenon
making the thumbs up gesture like a
nerdy tourist oh
god i'm doing it if i go there i'm
gonna do that for sure i'm in west
africa a bunch and
um where i'm this this is this is okay
okay yeah and there's only black people
there yeah so
nobody's getting mad at my okay symbol
they probably do it too
i've got a picture of beyonce doing it i
saved a bunch of pictures of uh
black folks doing the okay symbol i was
uh sending it to my friends
people were saying that there's
something wrong with the okay i'm like
you can't take away something that's
been around forever
that just means okay and the whole the
thing about
there were some people that were doing
it like upside
down so that's a military thing oh okay
explain that
um it's an [ __ ] this is an [ __ ]
so the game is um at any moment
you know we're talking over here you're
like oh man i hurt my leg down here
and if you look at it i gotcha and i get
to flick you in the dick
really yeah so like pop wait a minute
but
you can cancel it if you can get your
finger in there
yeah so it's a game that has existed in
every single basic training
you have to remember that the audience
that we're talking about here like these
guys are volunteering to go to war so
they're not right right but i mean this
this for as long as i've been in the
military for 16 years
this is an [ __ ] and the game has
always been like gotcha
it's a gotcha moment if they look down
at it so if you do that
that that thing and then someone sees it
they have to stick their finger in it or
you hit them in the dick yep okay yeah
that's the game rules to the game
like two years ago i still would play
this with my friends but it became this
whole thing but
i'd never heard of this it could also be
internet 4chan meme [ __ ] where they're
taking it to another level and giving
would you remember when those cops they
all got in trouble because they were
taking a picture
and everyone's saying these cops are
doing the white power
thing but you're saying that's not what
that is at all so west point at one of
the recent graduations i think trump
spoke there
um a bunch of the west point graduates
were doing that symbol because it's a w
and a p yeah well that's what
the the article was like oh no a bunch
of white supremacists are graduating
from west point
and so there's a huge military
investigation i mean pentagon sending
people out
to research this and they're like oh
shoot it's
them playing an [ __ ] game this is
this is actually not better because now
our west point the most prestigious
military academy
our graduates are playing their senior
year at a trump graduation
the [ __ ] game and the [ __ ] game
has consequences
and those are dick's labs yep that's
right unless you get your finger in
there and then you're safe
that's so [ __ ] ridiculous
we have to we have to like amuse
ourselves well the problem is with
someone to be able to write an article
like that
and say this is a white power symbol and
then all of a sudden these people get
labeled as white supremacists and then
there's no repercussion because once the
article's out there even if you have a
retraction
the art the original article is still
out and the damage is done done
done and those guys are labeled as white
supremacists when they're really just
dorks
yeah have you ever read a retraction not
one
no no i don't believe i have no i mean
maybe someone's
showed me one a couple of times but when
someone gets accused of something like
that that's a pretty heinous thing
like retraction's not going to reach the
same amount of people
no i would be enraged if somebody was
like hey you're a white supremist
because you did this thing and i was
like
no i'm not always premised and um that
thing is an
[ __ ] um like how are we gonna
equal this out here that's not
forgivable they should be sued
it's like you're doing some some
irreparable damage to someone
it's just so weird today everyone it's
just like i can't imagine
a time where people are more outraged
about more things
yeah i i i really think it's just you
see more people but i really just think
it's a small percentage of people that
are always outraged
yeah on both sides all the time but they
have an opportunity to talk about it
more now yeah because
we're all connected and they can piss
other people off i just want to go
both sides and like give people big
hairy ogre troll hugs
i'd be like it's all gonna be okay you
know like we love you it's fine
yeah please stop tweeting
like trump just give me your phone
you're not allowed to tweet anymore
at least he's funny sometimes sometimes
sometimes he's [ __ ] funny man he
makes me laugh like one out of ten times
i will laugh out loud at his tweets yeah
you know yeah first of all sometimes i
laugh out loud because i can't believe
he's the [ __ ] president
i can't believe that guy's the president
yeah and then he'll say some ridiculous
[ __ ]
and i'll just go oh my god when he
called the girl that he [ __ ] that uh
that porn star when he called her horse
face on twitter
i was like this is amazing this is so
crazy
i'm amazed at that man is the president
right now
president acting president telling a
woman he [ __ ] horse face yeah
oh my god it's just just the weirdest 20
20 what it what a time
oh it's amazing but i mean you know
there's there's some
i wish i could be doing stand-up right
now you know if i could do stand-up it
would be more fun because it'd be stuff
i mean so much material out in here but
yeah but actual material that you could
work out about today
holy [ __ ] there's never been a bigger
gold mine that we hit yeah everybody's
like get the pans out of the river i
don't think you're allowed to talk about
it though
oh yeah yeah you are i mean yeah i know
you think that
comedians should be allowed as as i do
i think comedy is um the best way to
address
socially sensitive issues yeah like if
you can't
one of the things about the military is
there's a lot of dark humor and people
kind of look at us as these scarred um
damaged people because of that humor but
the truth is like we're able to
talk about those things through this
humor and whether it's like a release
for post-traumatic stress or just how
we're able to get to the next day
how we're able to go and do some of the
things that we do it's because we're
allowed to joke and laugh
and burn that stuff off these sensitive
times and i think that's what comedy
does
to these socially charged issues yes
and um you know jp sears
uh long-haired kind of hippie
youtuber he he has been recently kind of
attacking how comedians can't make jokes
right now
and how everything um has been charged
and there's not
a way like you can't make racist
sexist um
jokes or political jokes whatsoever
without being canceled and i was like
that's the best time to do it
yeah ari shafir had the best quote about
that he said
this is a great time for comedy because
comedy's actually dangerous again
ah that's cool it's actually dangerous
yeah whereas like five years ago you
would say something people didn't like
it they didn't come see you
yeah now they're they'll attack yeah and
you have consequences
but i think you just have to structure
your bits better you have to you have to
treat them
like uh doug stanhope has a great quote
that he was talking to me about he said
i go over my bits like i'm a defense
attorney like i i like i am i'm
going over my bits like i'm being
prosecuted for with you know
so someone's using them the bit against
me and so i have to figure it out like a
defense attorney i'm like that's a great
way of looking at it yeah but what a
horrible
approach in the process to it isn't it
isn't because he writes the joke first
and then he figures out how to make it
bulletproof you know
well i i have my method is usually i
[ __ ] on myself
so hard that by the time i get to
[ __ ] on someone else yeah
like i've already figured out like most
of my bits that are controversial they
start out with me
belittling myself like in the the most
vicious way i can like
explaining what a [ __ ] idiot i am and
then all the dumb [ __ ] that i've done
that's related to this thing and like
when i wanted to make a joke about
caitlyn jenner
what i talked about was the first thing
i talked about is how
living with all women i have three
daughters and my wife like
and then the way i described it was it's
like if my manhood
was a mountain of marbles every day
they'd take two
like you have so many marbles god is
everyday snatch a marble snatch marble
and my whole bit was getting to i was
one i wanted to get to people are saying
he was born a woman he's always been a
woman i was like
maybe or maybe
if you live with crazy [ __ ] long
enough oh they
they [ __ ] turn you into one yeah
maybe you go crazy maybe that too
especially those ones especially those
ones and so i had to figure out a way to
do
and so i came up with this thing where
they're demons and they they whisper in
his ear in the middle of the night and
they talk him into being a woman
but it took forever to figure out a way
but i have but it worked
like it worked and people didn't even
get mad at me for it i just had to
figure out a way to do it
where first of all i belittle myself and
then i explain it in a way where it's
not
it's not dehumanizing trans people it's
just it's like saying
are we sure yeah are we sure we lost a
[ __ ] olympic gold medalist god damn
it
we we lost one of our greatest athletes
ever you look in the record book what
does it say now
under bruce jenner what does it say i
don't know is
you even allowed to say that anymore i
don't think you can wikipedia is going
to put up whatever they want
um which won't be factual but yeah how
how would the record
books portray how they handle it if you
say that on twitter you'll get banned
for life if you call him bruce jenner on
twitter
it's dead naming they'll ban you for
life
good to know it's hilarious yeah that
that vexes me in a different way
yeah yeah the fact that you have to
think about a joke and it's
political or cancel culture
ramifications to make sure it's
politically correct enough for it to be
bulletproof
whether you're like your defense
attorney that sucks to me it doesn't it
doesn't
because it is a it's an opportunity to
make your jokes better and you can just
make them
and then again if you can get away with
it yeah it's more sweet
it's more juicy yeah but man i've uh
really liked that first amendment thing
you know yeah and i really like being p
people being able to say things that
make my blood boil and i don't want them
to say things that
are like i don't want to drink this
coffee when it's lukewarm
right and i think that's what
conversation is when you're pla when
you're everything politically correct
is just this disgusting gross version if
i'm gonna have champagne i want to be
freaking cold yeah you know perfect 30
36 degrees
um i don't want lukewarm coffee i don't
lukewarm champagne
i want perfect and that's what that's
what
communication is and when you start
neutering um
how someone can talk like that that's
not being able to express
an idea you're limiting the counter to
that though is that
when you do get away with it it makes it
even more powerful
yeah i'm telling you man the jokes that
i've said on stage that
are against political correctness that
are good like the way i've figured out a
way to weave some of them
when they hit man they hit like a bomb
like the whole room was like black
like they know i go you know i'm right
you know what i'm saying like i'm not a
bad person you know what i'm saying
like i have this this whole chunk that i
do
on on banning words and the whole
chunk it's like it took forever to
figure out how to manipulate it and get
it
to this place where it's you could sneak
it in on people and sneak in on people
that would
ordinarily say those words in in a
polite company and people would
their [ __ ] would tense up but you
can get it in and when you get it in woo
it's sweet yeah but i'm with you man you
know i want whiskey to get me drunk
i don't want fake whiskey nope yeah i'm
not interested
i think there should be consequences i
think i think the best way to combat
things that you disagree with
is to say how you feel
not not to say that person shouldn't be
able to say that that's ridiculous
that's dumb i was watching this video
yesterday and these guys were just
saying dumb [ __ ]
we were talking about people getting
cloned in china and this lady goes
deep platform that [ __ ] seriously she's
like like what
no i want dumb people to say dumb things
yes especially
our politicians like the i think the art
of listening has been lost
um one of the best things about i think
this podcast is that
you're a good listener right it takes it
takes a decently smart human
that has a self-confidence and developed
interpersonal skills to listen
that's lost in current culture where um
i i'm gonna get so visceral this this
really outraged at something that
somebody's saying
i can't even hear their point of view um
even if
that point of view is wrong you want
that person to say that yeah and the
dumber it is the more i want them to say
it because the dumber they sound
and the more we collective logical
reasonable person
people are like well that person's
really dumb and his ideas are not going
to work
so let's not follow him anymore and then
we're able to
to have a counter this is what's wrong
with what that person said
but the idea you're supposed to
de-platform them so bad
it's so stupid because then what if
someone thinks that they should
de-platform you
and i think you probably should be deep
platform for telling people they should
be de-platformed how about that yeah if
you're the person that
if that's more dangerous than some dummy
thinking that they're cloning people in
china
and by the way they might be cloning
people i just don't know i mean who the
[ __ ]
look they can clone people we know that
we know anybody's going to do it
yeah they're going to do it they'll
probably do that they're probably doing
it look
i i mean it's probably the least of our
concerns
you know i mean as far as overpopulation
goes i mean china's trying not to have
as many people
they mean they had a wall the whole
one-child policy forever yeah it turned
out to be disastrous and
tilted everything extraordinarily male i
mean i would not be
want to be a man in china trying to find
a woman
no right i mean i don't know if that
balance that out yet but that was a real
issue for a long time
i wouldn't want to be in china at all um
because i'm a big fan of freedom yeah
yeah freedom's nice
pretty pretty it's pretty powerful it's
goddamn important when you say deep
platforming people
you you don't think you're taking away
freedom but you are yeah you're taking
away a little bit of freedom
and i i think it's extra important right
now where people have been
isolated for this whatever six five
months now
from covid where
they're creating echo chambers when
they're when they curate their own
information access we're like i'm not
going to listen to this guy or i want
this guy to be platformed or any of the
social medias obviously
are are limiting what kind of voices are
being heard um
while you're sitting there at home for
the past four months
and you're just in this echo chamber of
your own ideas and people that agree
with you
it magnifies and radicalizes
what you believe and there's no logical
sound
sound board there's no bounce off
there's no pressure check
there's no refiners fire to those ideas
because it's an echo chamber yeah and
like you're reading the exact same
things on twitter you're seeing the same
things on facebook
you're looking at the same things on
instagram then you turn on the tv and of
course they're saying all the same
things that you already agree with
they're just these ideas continue and
gain momentum and they're not real
because they've never been tested
against anything that disagrees with
them
or that that contradicts them and all i
think all ideas have to go through that
process
for them to be real is that that that
refiners fire
of is this really going to work let's
apply pressure and find out
yeah there's this is defund the police
thing that's going around right now my
friend matt had this funny thing that
happened he has a son
his son's about 25 i think he said and
uh his son
uh was talking about defunding the
police and he's arguing with him his
son's you know real liberal in the whole
deal
uh then his son is staying at they have
a beach house and it's an old house and
the house is making like some crazy
noises he ran
outside and called his dad and he said
there's something going on the house
i'm going to call the police he goes i
thought you wanted to defund the police
he goes now the [ __ ] house is haunted
and you're calling the police
you went from defund the police to the
house is making noise
let me call the cops yeah that's that's
a pretty fast jump
uh i mean that's not only idiotic it's
dangerous
it's dangerous and stupid and it's
everything
it's everything wrong with these ideas
that just get propagated online that no
one really thinks through but then they
get
they become a thing that you if you're
cool you say it
if you're in the right group you say it
and that's what defund the police is
and even fighting against those ideas
for some reason you
like if i i believe def defunding the
police is the dumbest thing you could
possibly do
do i think there might be problems
within law enforcement that should be
addressed
for sure for sure like how do you fix
those you need funding you need funding
right like
um i have a school that's
underperforming kids are not graduating
from high school do what we should do
we should take money from the school and
we should give them fewer teachers and
let's see if that's going to help
no that's not going to help right you
have to give them more teachers you have
to give them more funding you have to
give them more access to information
and then maybe that school starts
performing a little better
a police department is no they're just
humans
right they're imperfect they need
training they need funding they need
support
right now they need morale and they need
people um
and they need to get rid of the people
that suck yeah they need those things
too and one of the best ways to do that
is through training
you weed people out you find out who
can't cut it that's what that's what
it's supposed to be for
yeah the the one of the best things
about
special operations is that there's so
much
training and process the refiners fire
the chaff in the wind
like you throw that stuff up and the
crap blows away and the good stuff comes
back down
then you take that stuff and you go and
carry it into a fire and then you heat
it and then you pull it out and you
pound it then you heat it again you
pound it then heat it you pound it
and what you're left with at the end is
this pretty
cool thing
if any of that is with law enforcement
that all of those things can only occur
through training
and and like if you want to test
somebody if you want to
check if you want to find racism like
having them show up to work for eight
hours and letting them hop in a car and
run out um you're never going to know
what's inside of there
the only time you get access that you
get peaks of that is it
at these stressful emotionally drained
moments
yes and the only time that you can
create those is through training
i've been arguing that we should have
that for all of our leaders
like when we were talking about the
mayor of california or the
the mayor of los angeles and the
governor of california and the people
that are deciding you can't
trick-or-treat this year this is the new
thing the one [ __ ] holiday where you
have to wear a mask
you're supposed to wear a mask and they
for whatever reason they've decided
they're going to save people
by stopping little kids the ones who
have the least problem with this disease
from trick-or-treating it's [ __ ]
asinine
it's so dumb and i think part of it is
because the people that are in that
position the people that are in the
position of control
they don't have to be tested they don't
have to show their character they just
have to win a popularity contest that
no one wants to enter no one wants to be
the [ __ ] mayor of la
who's entering no one wants to be the
governor of california how many people
self-serving people are entering you
know mayor adler
here in austin you know like yeah same
[ __ ]
yeah just get get out of here yeah is it
is there a public servant that wants to
step up you know i want eminem to sing
that song
with a real public servant step up
there's there's nobody
but they they get so scrutinized and
it's such a ruthless business
yeah that the only people that you get
left are these wishy-washy milky people
yeah i i do wish that you know political
parties were afraid of the people again
yeah that that created a really healthy
balance where
um they understand that they are
represent that they represent their
constituents
and their job is to do what their people
want
once they get into this certain level of
political power
they kind of just do whatever they want
and they forget that
they're supposed to be representing the
people i've never seen california so
charged right now against california
like people are mad you know the
protests in long beach in san diego
and uh mar-a-lago like it's crazy the
number of people that are coming out
and being like i'm not okay with what's
happening right now
and they shouldn't be it's insane well
they've given dorks the ability to tell
people they can't work yeah that's what
it is
yeah and that's governor newsom and
mayor garcia those guys are dorks
and they're in control of whether or not
people can take risks and work
how can somebody tell you not to work
it's not scientific it's not politically
correct
even if it were scientific yeah how can
you tell me not to work
right but you can't well the idea is
that you're putting other people at risk
by working because if you get infected
other people are going to get infected
too
this is this is the idea behind but it's
a super flawed idea i'll super
i'll one i'll volunteer to inject my
neck with a hypodermic needle full of
covid
compared to my children starving to
death because i don't work yeah
and and some like the salon owners are
like if i don't open up
i'm i'm already four months behind on my
on my mortgage or
my rent um to include this building i'm
going to be homeless as are my kids
and you're going to be dealing with that
next month if i don't open right now
so people are just leaving the state
they're like well i'm going to go
somewhere where i have freedom
that's why so many people are coming
here to texas yeah well they better
remember why they left
exactly that's important i wanted to
talk to you about that i want to have
texas politicians on too
try to explain what the checks and
balances are in this state that have
kept it from being [ __ ] up and given
it the freedom that
it enjoys right now and one of the
reasons why people are coming here in
the first place
in droves yeah i mean from new york and
california
i've i i argue if you walk
downtown austin um if you walked even up
north like
um lamar palmer and you usually hey
where you from
four out of five people are going to be
from california new york
and like you're not you're not from
texas to include myself
and you know and you like oh are you
from originally
california central california how did
you get out here
um after
9 11 happened i enlisted and you know
georgia fort bragg deployments georgia
fort bragg deployments that
cycle um when i was fighting i
i like texas and i could kind of live
anywhere if i was going to go to new
mexico and do my training camps
um my wife is from the south so she
wanted to live in the south
she's from louisiana she took a dog she
was a government contractor so she took
a government contracting job here
and um you know it was we knew we were
gonna be in texas we didn't know where
and austin felt like california
so that's really how we ended up here is
um they have a special opera they have a
huge
outside of fort bragg north carolina
this has the largest
group of special operations
in in the entire country really yeah
interesting yeah
how'd that happen um i
texas has the ideals that we kind of
stand for i actually have a present for
you from the texas
special operations community they're
like wait a second
so um they uh when i say
they come here in droves we we have
hundreds of green berets in the state of
texas in
from they're border patrol workers that
are still serving
as green berets they're police officers
firefighters
work for fbi but they live in texas
so they can be texans that are green
berets that then have their
their other shenanigan awesome jobs it's
huge
wow yeah you're surrounded by them i
didn't know
well they figured out it's awesome here
it is awesome it's very unusual i
almost feel uncomfortable talking about
how great it is here yeah i'm going to
make you uncomfortable in a little bit
when i give you a present okay give it
to me now if i can huh
all right so we can do this in texas
oh it's gone um well these are cigars
i know they're important it's just as
from the special operations forces
deopress the bear and
range lead the way it's our motto all
right thank you liberators of the
oppressed
damn that smells good
all right one of these is yours and one
of these is yours
i have to see which ones all right so
this one's yours there's a pocket
constitution
so anytime you're like man what are we
supposed to do in this instance you can
just pocket constitution i love it yeah
you
just reference real fast damn this
smells great you know we're talking
about the first amendment
congress shall make no law respecting
any establishment or religion
prohibiting the free exercise thereof of
abridging the freedom of speech
to press the red people to peacefully
assemble
petition the government for redress of
grave grievances so this has all of them
in here
all right so this gun i i took it has
been shot so i zeroed it for you
beautiful um got your
texas they bring you guns no it's got a
loophole
loophole delta point red dot on there i
love leupold so this is like ready to
ready uh ready to go it's zeroed it's um
fn 509 compact
paula hello jamie you got a gun now are
you excited
so that is no longer my gun that is your
gun thank you very much jamie have you
ever shot a gun
i've shot your gun oh
so this adjusts to i can put this on
anything in like your bag or a fanny
pack
um if not i'll get you a concealed carry
holster like that i love this holster
thanks yeah it's pretty handmade so this
is an fn 503
single stack nine millimeter so this is
like what you could carry
here around austin and uh but this is
very nice compact gun a lot of
people right now uncomfortable
they've got guns are you uncomfortable
nope
this is your first gun come here come
here come here give me
give me a hug give him a hug come here
[Laughter]
there we go listen boom
welcome you can see i got my first gun
from tim [ __ ] kennedy yeah how
about that
and you never forget that that was
because you came to texas
we're going to go to the range with tim
and alex jones how about that
texas only uh i think it's a halloween
thing you can shoot zombies
you can get in a group and shoot zombies
not with real guns obviously but like
some
zombie kill it like real people probably
dressed up like zombies that'll take
painful hits
really yeah yeah and somebody said it to
be like let's go
we have like um responsive targets that
are built like zombies
so you shoot them and like blood comes
out and we have um
they call them heavy metal zombie
competitions so it's like a three gun
competition
so you have to shoot 45 308 and 12 gauge
um and you only head shots count
so as you zombie safari
sounds like fun right yeah i wish i came
here years ago
zombie safari dallas is open every
friday and saturday in october
well we're going yeah we have to go to
that
weather's cooling off so we're going to
do a lot more helicopter pig hunts
2 400 rounds kill zombies now when you
do the helicopter pig hunts um
how do you guys gather up the meat do
you have someone that
drives after the helicopter depends on
where we're going and what we're doing
so
some some ranches um we are
exterminating
so they don't even gather up to me no
wow and some of them are disgusting
but the meat's still good no it's not
gross really no why
they're like like you get an old male
like maggoty
rancid gross tough meat i don't want
that
you get like a young sow yeah
but those old ones though seriously if
you put them on a smoker and you do it
right
you brine them they still taste good
okay why
when you have five billion
pigs in texas why would you cook a nasty
one or did you just
go get a nice sweet one over there and
there's so many of them
like if we go next week i take you you
would shoot
50 pigs why i'm a helicopter from
helicopter
why would you pick a gross one i see
what you're saying but it just seems
like
you don't want to waste the meat though
i mean there are people that would
like that we'll talk about no
no food wise if we're gonna compare food
meat to
so on a on a farm 25 of your crop
is destroyed by feral pigs yes every
year so no problem here if you're if
you're
if you had a million dollars you're
automatically off the top 250 000
of your crop is gone to feral pigs so
you as a rancher
you're like i've seen uh heavy-handed
hairy ogre like me
they're like wait you'll come and kill
pigs on my property
and you don't i don't have to do
anything they'll
welcome you how many times have you done
this
i don't know [ __ ] a thousand i don't
know
i have no idea a thousand times from
helicopters
oh what a great place to be yeah but
it's different shooting though because
instead of
a pot so if something's moving fast um
like a vehicle if i was going to be
engaging something moving let's say from
the right to the left
yeah you have to lead it well when
you're in a helicopter you actually have
to give a what
a negative lead so you're gonna shoot
behind it you're going too fast yeah so
whatever speed if you're going let's say
80 knots you're gonna have to be behind
it about about the tail
and the speed of that helicopter is
gonna make up the difference to give you
a middle
impact oh interesting how fast is the
helicopter going when you're shooting
um depends on the pilot and like
sometimes that's you as a shooter you're
just kind of having to judge how fast
you're going
and um shane who will fly with
he's a great pilot and uh so he'll like
camp the
helicopter like a 45 degree angle and
open up the shooter door
towards so we're only probably going
like 30
knots so you can not in miles an hour
like uh one and a half
why do they use nuts i don't know it's
naval and aviation
use it just to confuse people yeah
yeah but at that speed you can aim point
and point impact
right just rack them up yeah wow have
you shot
an fn 509 before no they're really good
yeah yeah
striker fire you shoot glock yeah it's
real similar trigger
a little bit more combat feely um that's
the compact
so you can i don't know do you care yet
i don't have a concealed carry we're
gonna fix that okay
like super fast all right excellent good
here yeah you can't be here
i gave you concealed carry state right
open carries dome
please don't do that yeah it's it's like
very uh
antagonistic almost yeah uh but like
you that's um while i believe you have
the right to do that
it's also one of those things that's
like it's also dumb to do it
from a tactical perspective right why
would you
be sitting here with the thing that you
want right to protect you
exposed to the whole entire world and
telegraphing
like if i walk into a room that's like
the first guy i'm like
one you're probably useless two is um
i'm concerned about you not as an asset
but rather as a threat
right like there's um i don't there's
not if you went out to any any of
the guys out here or any of my friends
you're like do you open carry they're
like
no that's dumb i'm not gonna do that
well that's that thing that
like i was getting into about the
protest when people were showing up at
these uh black lives matter protests
with uh ak's around their neck
what are you doing how many times they
have accidentally discharged
their weapon into the crowd oh i'm sure
it's it's happened like a dozen times
i'm sure it's it's heartbreaking because
like i respect that they're trying to
like i fully believe in protesting love
peaceful protests
i even like that that kind of bravado of
open carry in that sense where they're
like really i think a freedom not
exercised is a freedom that's going to
atrophy and die
one of the reasons why i love comedy is
because um you are pushing the limit
of what people are comfortable with
especially with the first amendment
so you're kind of torn on open carry in
that sense
i think it's super dumb but i like
people exercising their freedoms
interesting yeah i see what you're
saying though
uh the right person like i won i would
never be at a protest of
um while like support it i would
i it's dangerous to be there right now
um
so i wouldn't the cost versus gain of
what happens at those peaceful protests
um
and then the the thought of even open
carrying is is idiotic
i agree with that i i feel like showing
up at one of those protests with a gun
like
unless they're coming to you and trying
to take your house or
break down your door why do you have a
why are you walking around with a gun
just you're supposed to if it's supposed
to be a peaceful protest
and the idea is like what if someone
comes to try to disrupt that peaceful
protest like
you're inviting them almost with that
gun yeah i mean we had a
a poor um kid killed here in austin um
he had an ak and a poor uber driver
got in the middle of a protest and he's
like holy crap
his his you know when he dropped he had
a drop off
and he went to go do another pickup and
uber like automatically routes
the the way to go so he's following his
little uber route and he turns and he's
like
oh man i'm in the middle of a protest
he's a soldier from fort hood
right here and he's concealed carrying
in
in in his uber vehicle and um he gets
stuck in the protest
and the protesters just swarm his car
and this
this this kid that died um he's actually
a really neat kid
because you know his his girlfriend um
was black and he's there to support her
um she had a bunch of physical physical
impairments and she's in a wheelchair
yeah yeah so i mean he's like a neat kid
you're like not smart
he's open caring at a protest you know
and he was saying kind of some
inflammatory things beforehand but like
i think his point and his purpose was
really good
and pure and like trying to do the right
thing right um but then he runs up to
the side of a car
and points a gun at an uber driver that
is scared and confused
and he gets shot yeah like that's the
recipe for disaster
i saw so many different versions of that
story too
where people had twisted the facts
people had said he was unarmed
people the guy who got shot people were
saying that the guy who did it was a
white supremacist who drove into the
protest on purpose
there was so many the video was edited
where it looked like the guy was making
a right-hand turn
and he like sped up because he was
trying to get around a person and they
cut right there because it looks like
the guy's speeding up to go into the
crowd but super when you watch the whole
video it's really obvious what that poor
kid was trying to do with the driver
i saw a fascinating this phd
on communication broke down from the
initial
release of the information of the story
how it immediately
started being um distorted yeah for two
different sides
like i'm gonna leave out this detail i'm
gonna include this to detail
and by the time you got you know the
game telephone where you're like hey um
here's this catch phrase and by the time
it gets all the way around the room
it doesn't sound like any semblance of
what it did when it started
when you got to the final version i'm
super enraged
at one version and i'm super enraged at
another version but neither of them are
true
and like that that's what every single
issue
is happening from defunding the police
to black lives matter
to antifa it's like can we just be
reasonable and talk about
what's really happening and we have some
real good examples
of what the worst case scenarios are in
this country right now and one of us
portland
yeah like portland is one of the best
case scenarios of
completely unreasonable ridiculous [ __ ]
that's going on every single day
a hundred and one days approach that guy
that [ __ ] mayor up there is the most
progressive mayor in the country and
they're like [ __ ] you
resign we're gonna burn your house he
had to move out because they're gonna
burn his place down well they tried to
burn down his lobby
they were throwing fiery things into his
lobby they were lighting fires in front
of the street in front of his house
having dance parties in front of his
apartment building so i was just coming
back
from africa on an sfa mission um
a security forces assistance like a
we the military go to places that have
insurgents
and we try to legitimize the process of
government
so in insurgency there's like all of
these different missions from
um joint combined exercises for training
to foreign internal defense
to sfas security forces um
assistance and i'm over there doing a
counter-insurgency mission and i'm
coming back
and i'm seeing the same kind of horrible
dangerous recipe
in portland you know the the same
types of organization and structure
and and it's an insurgency
is a charged idea that
you know insurgency as the dod defines
it is
a an organized group trying to
delegitimize
or overthrow a constitutional government
like that's how the
dod defines it and i think if you went
to
almost anyone in portland they're like
what are you trying to do right now
like that's what they're trying to do
yeah right like that's what they believe
they're open about it
yeah which is all right and
that creates a really hard um
how do you combat that because you have
to combat the grievances
and the ideas you have to in as
dangerous as it is
those ideas are like a cancer because
when the truth and information is being
uh adjusted just like we talked about
with the shooting here in austin
where you have two different versions
and some people are in the echo chamber
of only hearing one side of it it just
keeps radicalizing
more and more and catching more momentum
and then the reason that they're there
is is so convoluted with
you know if you're are you there for
black lives matter or are you there
um you know to fight systemic racism are
you here to like what are you protesting
about
like i think you'd get a lot of
different answers yeah that's dangerous
like now now now you're just there to do
damage like you're not really trying to
do anything that's good
what's also exciting this is the other
thing about it when
when you're allowed to throw fire into
the lobby
of the apartment building where the
mayor lives
and no one stops you and you're out in
front and people are playing music
and dancing and everyone's going black
lives matter
there's excitement to that right
something's happening
and then when you're talking about
people that are out of work the economy
is [ __ ] no one knows what to do
everyone's scared
kovid's killing a certain percentage of
people
you you can't do anything about it
there's no vaccines
there's all this tension in the air and
then you have this movement
yeah and then this is the most exciting
thing that's happening and
and then for people that don't have jobs
and can't go anywhere
what the [ __ ] do you want them to do
they're going to get sucked up into that
especially if it aligns with their
political ideologies
they're a left-leaning person and
they're like look we have a real chance
for a real revolution here and this is
but what what they don't understand what
i was talking about seattle
you're doing the same thing that you
would hate
for people to do you're taking over
businesses with
force you're you're occupying land that
you don't deserve
you're stealing buildings you're
literally occupying buildings that other
people built
and then once you get there you're
establishing boundaries
you're putting up barriers you have a
police force that will attack
and brutally beat people up for just
filming what they perceive as injustices
or what they're going to put on the
internet and then people get shot and
you're calling the [ __ ] cops
you call the police and ambulances when
people get shot there yeah you know how
goddamn crazy this is it's so poorly
thought out
across the board and if you do that if
you take over an area
what's to stop people from doing that to
you
you've already set a precedent you've
already said we could do this with force
we're going to move in
with no law behind us with no court
ruling with no reasonable discourse
we're going to move in with force and
we're going to take over near with
numbers and threats
and then what's going to stop someone
from doing that to you nothing you [ __ ]
you've already set a precedent you've
already said this is how it's done
yeah and then it's just chaos and
anarchy like it just gets worse exactly
and the more violent and larger group
will win
so from a the the mission
of counterinsurgency like how do you
fight those ideas is stability and
security right
if we want um to see positive change and
and
you know kind of destitute
poverty-stricken areas of the country
um urban areas where like really you
want to talk about systemic racism you
start looking at like detroit
and baltimore and chicago um how do you
fix that
it's not fewer police officers it's more
police officers
the way that you fix it is providing
providing stability and security in an
area so that then businesses can
flourish capitalism arrives
more job opportunities more wealth more
education
more like immediately in 10 years you'll
see
the the transformation of a block when a
when a good business comes in
and good things start happening that
business can't go there
if it's dangerous if it's riding and
it's looting so if you look at every
one of the cities that had serious riots
um in
you know from like rodney king how bad
those areas still are
it takes like 50 60 years if they ever
bounce back
to come back from that so if you're like
yo go black
lives matter but then you're going in
rioting you are absolutely condemning
yourself
to more poverty and then you go and
defund the police and you remove
the one thing that's going to provide
stability and security out in that area
that will bring in commerce that will
bring in business and jobs
like your screwing yourself
it's just so hard for people to see that
because it's a long game yeah
and in the short term they want justice
and they're like no justice no peace and
they just want to light [ __ ] on fire
and i i understand that they're angry
and i understand that sentiment but it
so
no one's explaining that this is this is
how this plays out you're literally
gonna [ __ ] that area yeah
for a long time yeah yeah it takes a
long and a lot of money is gonna be
have to be spent in order to bring it
back so the money is a hard
thing um insurgencies are really cheap
you know if um if i wanted to ruin
something
you know it doesn't take a lot of effort
for me to destroy it
for me to build and protect something
that takes a lot of manpowers and
manpower and hours um insurgencies are
also way more successful
than a you know conventional type war
even if it's just war of ideas not that
we're in a civil war
thank god we don't have like geographic
lines that these
radical groups could align themselves
with because then it would be in a
different problem
um it takes not just manpower
funding uh you know if you're going to
flood say baltimore
with police officers that's a lot of
money and it would take a long time
for a business to feel like it's safe
and secure
for them to go in there and start
affecting positive change
opening more stores more jobs more jobs
more wealth more wealth more education
more education better schools
and then boom we have a flourishing
community where people can
prosper um but it takes
you know one idiot with a molotov
cocktail to bring that all crumbling
down again
yeah and you start from scratch or below
scratch yeah
yeah that's where we are yep i mean this
is a
trying time for us in the weirdest of
ways because i don't think anybody
anticipated
everything going this far south so
quickly yeah it's not done oh this is
yours
what's that oh my constitution mm-hmm
back up
[ __ ] yeah i got the papers yeah just
how it is independence
not for interpretation it's just as it
is just read the words uh just amazing
that these guys
saw human nature and how it could be
[ __ ] up
and how they could ruin everything so
far in advance
do you smoke cigars i don't you don't at
all no i'm a pretty
straight edge-ish person don't drink at
all
i'll have like a a glass of wine every
other night
it's good for your blood it's good for
your heart allegedly
that's what they say yeah that's the
extent of it yeah but you know those are
like epidemiology studies
yeah it's like how many people have a
glass of wine every other night how are
they doing
and look at them it's not like they've
proven a glass of wine
does x or y it also tastes really good
with elk tastes good
yeah i like it with steak yeah i'm a big
fan of red meat and
and uh red wine yeah it's a good
combination that's the i have a
big pretty liquor cabinet of nothing
that i ever drink that people just give
me
so when people come over i'm like yeah
you can no mushrooms no psychedelics no
i've never done anything ever what
nope that might be part of your problem
i have lots of problems
there's no doubt that that is on the
long dignified list of we've thought
about it
thought about diving in man i have um i
have teenage daughters
that you know one's a freshman in
college one's a senior in high school
and um you know if i ever thought about
it it's go and then i have a
an 11 month old and a five-year-old so
dude you do a lot of [ __ ]
yeah all of them will be through school
before i ever thought about it
i get it my dad was a narcotics officer
oh that's what it is and uh
which was funny because i had like
intentionally just to make mad i had
friends that were drug dealers
but i would never i would never use but
i would be around it all the time
that's interesting how'd you avoid it um
being an athlete being a martial artist
being a fighter
i was more into you know being able to
beat somebody up then
not what was your first martial art that
you got into
uh karate what kind
shotakon and then i went to japanese jiu
jitsu after that
and takara kia jujitsu and i did that
for a while and then i ended up at the
pit
hawaiian kempo with john hackelman and
chuck and then san luis obispo
yep yep aurora grande and san luis bispo
yeah and then uh that's that uh my it
was actually jake shields
that brought me to the pit really yeah
he uh showed up
um so i was like uh
the big guy at the gym in grappling
right like wrestled
and so i could go in and kind of smash a
lot of the people and then
this kind of awkward weird white kid
comes in and just like
map like mops the floor with my soul and
i was like
who are you where did you come from and
what did you do like what what
is this he's like well it's it's like
catch wrestling you know which is kind
of like
jiu jitsu and wrestling kind of put
together you know and
and um but you know then we fight and i
think i was 16
at this 15 15 16 at this time he's like
can we in san luis obispo there's these
other guys that do it this gan mcgee and
scott adams and chuck liddell
and uh antonio banuelas cruz gomez
and uh and it's like cool i want to go
there
so i went there and got my brains bashed
in for
forever yeah is an interesting character
himself
he is he's quite a character yeah he
he's a great coach though um especially
back then
um he invested a lot and he was old
school
and i and guys like chuck and myself and
we needed old school
uh like now the coaches can't
do or say the things that john would say
back then
um and uh and i i love john now but
you know he was not a kind coach well
he's still training glover right
yeah he's got glow and then alex pereira
is with them now as well
which i thought was very interesting
yeah court mcgee is still in and out oh
is he yeah
court's had some injuries right yeah
yeah yeah i think his whole career has
kind of been like that
yeah that was a guy i was always on my
radar of like i thought i might fight
because when i went to jackson's you
know his clear break separation
um and he's in the pit in utah right
yeah yeah yeah he's got to stay healthy
he's a he's in he's one of those guys
that almost died and came back
because of drugs and there's a few of
those guys that are
almost unbreakable they like they they
almost die
and come back and then they become these
insanely disciplined people
and he's one of those yeah is that good
though to almost die
from drugs i don't think it's good okay
i think whatever led him to drugs he
probably could have squashed those
demons with training yeah
but the problem with there's many
obsessions
and addictions that come from
almost the same energy that could be
applied to something that makes you
incredibly successful
it's these where your brain is
fixated whether it's on gambling or
whatever it is whatever these addictions
are
they could ruin your life or you could
decide you're going to be the baddest
[ __ ] that ever lived and it's
the same kind of addictions
you know i've talked to tyson about this
i've talked to a bunch of fighters about
this that
have these addictive tendencies
but those tendencies are also obsessive
tendencies
which can be applied to something that
is ultimately positive like training
that's what i do yeah i have a huge i've
never had any addiction
um to negative stuff
but i think if you looked at my life
from how i train how i shoot
how i work how i run my companies you're
like this this guy's a psychopath
with the the the disciplined regiment
of of literal pain
and suffering that i intentionally put
my body through um
and that's to stay productive and so
it's all constructive
yeah i always joke that if i didn't do
martial arts
and fight and go into the military where
all of those things were encouraged
like yeah we want you to fight you know
we want you to kind of be a violent
badass
um i would be in prison you know i'd
like for sure
um probably a lot of people like that
yeah
a lot of people a lot of people that are
in prison that i to this day
feel like if we could have got them when
they were young and said hey
listen listen this is the path you're on
yeah but this is
this is a way better path you can get on
it's [ __ ] exciting
yeah and it's going to feel good yeah
yeah i mean it's painful
it's hard it's so rewarding though yeah
so rewarding trying to talk
convince somebody like to to buy into
this way of life
um you know and i i think like
you know hard work uh the
all the things that you want on the far
side of hard work and and
getting somebody to believe that where
they have to make all these kind of
small decisions where
am i you know waking up early am i not
going to be drinking
am i not going to be doing drugs am i
going to be training am i going to
all of these tiny little decisions start
adding up and um
like the titanic slowly turning the boat
you know but had they started turning
the boat earlier they wouldn't have
struck an iceberg and they all wouldn't
have died right
but so you have to start making all
these incremental adjustments and
like imagine what the titanic would have
been had it not struck the iceberg like
a connection between two worlds
you know the poverty being able to move
to a new world
and the rich elite been co-mingling and
like who knows what the world would have
been like had that
boat not sunk and it would have only
taken these small
early adjustments to see the whole
entire change of its course
but the belief right you're at the helm
and you're telling
me to to start moving to moving
the the boat i'm like i don't i don't
want to like i don't need to
all the excuses are there but it is so
rewarding to be on the far side of all
that
it's just people need to they need to
know
about these procrastination demons that
haunt your mind
and they will rob you of all possible
success of everything they'll steal
everything from you
yeah and like when people come to our
our courses um the the biggest thing
that we're trying to impart that like
i'm not gonna in
in two and a half days i'm not going to
turn somebody into a great fighter
i'm not going to turn somebody into a
great shooter in two and a half days
but what they're going to learn is
they're going to learn their assets and
their liabilities
and they're going to learn about
themselves about what do they need to do
that we're going to put them on a course
a direction a path
all the things they need to do to
positively change their life
and it becomes this this i'll use
addictive like this all-consuming
passion to want to know that your
family's safe to not
live in fear to know that you're healthy
you're like i have less body fat
i'm feeling kind of like a badass i like
want to flirt with my wife a little bit
more now i'm having more sex now my
energy's going up now i'm sleeping
better and the next day's even better
so i can train a little bit more i can
work a little bit more i can shoot a
little bit more
and then like the next day i'm even
better and like just one percent
incremental changes now two months
removed you're like
who is this person you just lost 20
pounds of fat like you've got calluses
on your hands
you don't have that fat baby chub on
your face anymore and more importantly i
see life in your eyes where you showed
up two months ago and there's like this
ghost skeleton of a human
now i see a person it's rad okay and i
get to see this transformation of people
it's one of my favorite things about
what i do
yeah it's so hard for people that don't
do it to understand that
if you do push your body it gets
stronger and you grow
and then you literally feel better i try
to explain it to a friend of mine i said
imagine
if you have a race car and the race car
is 400 horsepower and a certain width
tire and a certain kind of suspension
but literally you can make it have more
horsepower
and handle better and all you have to do
is work you just have to push it
and the tires will widen and the
suspension will toughen
and it'll be more more pliable around
corners
the the engine will get stronger the
exhaust will sound better
it'll be more rewarding to drive you can
do this yeah you can do with your body
like your body literally isn't your race
car yes and your mind your mind goes
along with it which is another thing
that
bums me out where really smart people
don't want to work out because they
think it's like
they think it's uh for meat heads or
they think it's
uh it's a stupid egotistical pursuit
like no you you literally
are all connected your brain and your
body are one
total human condition yes just because
you look if you're
a an awesome pianist right and you're
really good at playing the piano
you have to understand that that's not
just your fingers right that's your mind
your mind is also making you play the
piano well guess what if you were in
better cardiovascular shape
you probably could do that even better
because then the whole system would work
better
everything would work better and this is
the same with everything
yes you know everything everything's
going quicker you know and guys like
rachmaninoff
big huge powerful hands that could play
these big huge chords
like his body conditioned to be able to
do those things it wasn't like
immediately
he had this one and a half octave reach
right he learned and his hands literally
grew
to be able to play chords that if you
and i go and play them right now we have
carpel's tunnel in six months
you know like this his body adapted
evolved
to be able to play like just dun dun dun
dun dun
like that's so freaking cool i love
humans i love humans too
my friend cam haines does a bunch of
ultra marathons
i love that guy he's an awesome dude
yeah and he started out like
it's funny when i i talked to him like
when i started running it because i
barely run a mile
and that's and so someone's saying like
how the [ __ ] does someone run 240 miles
i go will you start by running a mile
yeah how do you start eating an elephant
yeah you start and you just you keep and
then next thing you know you can run
three miles and you can do it at a
comfortable pace and then
six months later you can run six miles
at a comfortable pace
and then six months after that you can
run a marathon at a comfortable pace
run an ultra marathon you gotta
keep you said six months though like
people want immediate
early gratification right like how can i
just hit a button or i just watch an app
or pull up a youtube video and teach me
how to do that yeah
because it takes work yeah that's the
thing yeah it's a thing
so how do you convince somebody to do it
because the
this idea this constitutional republic
that we're in
like it was possible because the
individuals were
strong self-sufficient and they believed
in individual responsibility
right and they had [ __ ] balls yeah
they're coming back
another huge powerful
i mean i'm gonna fight a bear like yeah
i start a republic start a whole new
thing that's another
concept no without that individual being
a freaking stud yeah right and not this
fat flagellate gelatin
human sitting on the couch playing video
games and
none of these ideas are possible if we
continue down the this soft
trajectory of wanting instant
gratification and believing that
we're entitled to anything we have to we
have to believe that you got to be a
badass for this to work
there's so many people that are
conditioned to instant gratification and
there's so many people that just want to
take a pill
that's that's that's another problem
with today you know you feel bad do you
feel bad
we need to take a pill or or go run four
miles
yeah and do what your brain does the
same freaking thing that your pill just
made you do but it happened naturally
and you'll be healthier and you're gonna
produce more of it tomorrow yeah
yeah you know like i don't know a lot of
really depressed frustrated sad
healthy smart people who exercise a lot
yeah
yeah no it's not i mean i'm sure there's
some i'm sure there are
absolutely some mental imbalances just
like some people have liver disease
right
and they don't even drink some people
they get cancer and they didn't do
anything wrong
because the body [ __ ] up sometimes that
also happens with your brain
it happens with hormones it happens with
the your brain your brain's ability to
produce dopamine and serotonin sometimes
it just doesn't work right no and that
is a that is a
a real thing but more often than not
that's not what's going on nope just go
do the work just go do the work yeah it
feels so good
and everything like how much do you love
eating your elk i love it
it's not only does it taste fantastic
right not only um
do you look at it and remember every
time i'm cooking whether like i had
lasagna the other night i took some
elk made italian sausage a little bit of
pork fat a bunch of italian
um you know oregano and thyme that were
mixed into the meat
uh so i made a lasagna with
ground backstrap and italian sausage
two nights ago but the like as i'm
cooking and
i'm remembering walking up this mountain
and seeing it two ridges away
and being like okay where's the wind
coming from how am i gonna button hook
around this thing
so that i can stay up wind of it and uh
catch it in this next ravine
you know and like every single moment
the smells and it's all coming back to
you and then i sit down at the table
i've got my family with me and we're
gonna eat this together
it's amazing it's like magical it's hard
for people to understand that i've never
done it before
but it is uh eating something that
you've hunted and killed yourself is a
different thing
it's a different thing it really is yeah
so fun though
in texas boy what a good place to do it
you can [ __ ] do it anywhere here
there's so many ranches here it's great
so much there's not a lot of public land
so it's gonna be a little bit different
only two percent yeah which is the whole
state which is kind of bonkers
yeah but i mean is the government really
supposed to be owning our land
well you just got all texas on me yeah
yeah i'm not opposed to owning property
and you can pay to hunt all these places
and most of these places are
um a lot of them i should say are
commercial hunting ranches and they're
not unreasonable
and you can go and for a small amount of
money when you think about the amount of
animal that you get i mean if you
hundreds of pounds yeah and especially
pigs like you get some wild first of all
wild pigs
you've eaten wild pigs they're i [ __ ]
love them i think they're goddamn
delicious
i love them you gotta get the right one
you gotta cut the right way well i've
got
i got lucky and the ones that i've
hunted have been at tohon ranch
in uh california and they eat a lot of
acorns oh wow they were real thick with
fat
oh my god they're so good i shot one
with john dudley
and we we brined it and slow cooked it
on the traeger it was incredible
i love the trigger oh i love it so easy
that's the thing
yeah i had this walk-in i mean it's half
the size of the studio
this walk-in smoker and it had the
eating heating elements
and the smoke element and i had it kind
of like insulated it was
um like i could hang an entire rack of
elk ribs in there
but i had to sit there 24 7
for however long i was going to sit
there and smoke this and uh
just too much adjusting smoke levels and
heat levels and
and then it's like oh now i can just put
this thing in my and walk inside with my
phone it's gonna check your text me
hey add add some more stuff in here yeah
i need more smoke and you're like oh my
god this is too easy even better i love
when you do a recipe
through the app the app actually
navigates the cooking cycle
and changes temperature for you but then
at the end of the day it's really just
fire and wood that's the beautiful thing
there's no chemicals there's no
gas there's it's just fire and wood yeah
so it tastes like you cooked it over an
open fire
so good it's [ __ ] awesome and wild
game that way is the best
yeah it's the best i mean there's a
reason why so many uh hunters buy
traegers
pellet grills any pellet grill if you
know a traeger pellet grills are the
[ __ ]
they're so good like i love how
easy it makes life you know like my um
my
outdoor kitchens next to the pool so i
go throw that stuff in there and i'm
like in the pool with the kids
yep mine too and it's just yeah i'm not
sitting over there wasting my whole
entire day and my kids are pissed you
know i'm like you better appreciate this
brisket
because i spent 14 hours on it you know
like that never happens like i put that
in there and i
appreciate old school like when i watch
uh the videos of franklin's
franklin's barbecue in austin that dude
he uses old-school
you know offset smokers with wood and
throws the wood in with the logs and
obviously the result is [ __ ] insanely
delicious
i appreciate it but i don't have time
for that bro that's his full-time job
you know aaron franklin i got it that's
amazing you keep doing that thing
i'll drive in and buy it when i need it
but i don't have the time to do that
and i love looking at my app like oh the
meat's at 120 degrees get ready to pull
it yeah that's
getting close and it sends you a little
notification
yeah no i love it i love it and i i
can't get enough wild game and i need to
bring more out here i didn't bring
enough out here i have i have it in
commercial freezers some of it back home
so
i literally might take a trip back home
just to fill up some coolers and bring
meat back
it's crazy um shipping it with dry ice
well if all you have to do is put it in
a yeti yeah if it's frozen
it'll you could send it regular ground
mail for five days
and it'll get their [ __ ] frozen it's
crazy how well those things keep
temperature
i i put on um either end
a little cardboard vertical separator
from the meat and then i pack dry ice in
there
and i just leave like an inch along the
top if i'm shipping stuff
um and then it just keeps it you know
super frozen for how long how long will
it last the dry ice
you know evaporates at the same weather
regardless of temperature so inside
there
that'll last for five days oh yeah
yeah it's uh it could be done yeah you
could ship it
what are you guys doing tomorrow 9 11.
well the reason why i had you on here
today is because this podcast is going
to be released on 9 11.
i think there's no more appropriate
person to have on 911
than you we have a podcast uh tomorrow
that we're doing a skype one with a
fellow from the uk the uh
there are way more appropriate people
than me um like any firefighter that was
there at ground zero have you been to
ground zero no
man you gotta go every american i think
new york city is off my list for life
now
yes that's a good point um
but being there and seeing kidding by
the way if you live in new york relax
i'm coming back
um they do a ton of comedy there yeah
they're still doing comedy there you
have to do it outside though in a
[ __ ] tent
yeah but don't people come by with
microphones and scream at you yeah
that's comedy too
[Laughter]
man uh john hackman and i talked this
week
um he called me and said hey what would
you do if
you're at a restaurant and you know
you're essentially ambushed
by people screaming at you trying you
know telling you to raise your foot to
raise your fist
um and like you know want to
not be there because i'd before i go
places i'm making sure that it's safer
to go there you know i'm not gonna be
sitting at a restaurant
where a protest is gonna be walking
through um
and i know there are targeting ones
specifically to try to catch people
and get the i gotcha moment uh two is
like you know situational awareness it's
not i'm sitting here and i see some
people congregating across the street
i'm gonna wait and see what happens now
there's a lot of people i see cameras i
see megaphones
i'm gonna still sit here and wait and
see what happens like i see like five
six people wearing black hoodies
masks you know with little red fists
painted on their shoulders i'm like huh
dinner's done we're out of here and we
pack up and go
um yes new york crazy
crazy place but that that memorial is
i don't know what it is about that place
like you can feel
i don't souls like you can feel
the pain there i think that's real i
think you can
my dad went to gettysburg and uh my
stepfather and he was there and he said
uh i've never believed that there's a
place where you could feel sadness
he goes but did you just feel the the
people that died there
that feel it i mean palatable
describable heaviness yeah and this is
not like i'm not
like i'm not a guy that you know like
they're crystals
no yeah but like you can feel it and
like never forget right how quickly we
forgot
um well they were trying to cancel the
[ __ ] putting up the the lights
yeah yeah like why why would you do that
have you seen the falling man
documentary
no so there's a photograph called the
falling man
um that it is you just google falling
man and you see
this guy and this this anytime i need to
know the reason why
i'm going all over these places doing oh
that's it dude oh [ __ ] i can't look at
it because it
like i mean it gets me because like
let's talk about this dude for a second
um he's sitting standing
um kneeling lane on the floor
of a shattered window and he's looking
back inside
and he's making the decision whether
he's going to burn alive or he's going
to jump to his death
him and hundreds others they're sitting
there americans
looking inside of a building being like
okay
do i burn alive or do i jump to my death
and that that video and that picture is
so
unnerving because he consciously is
making the choice
to die the whole entire way down you can
see he's staying
in like i'm going to face plant into the
asphalt
and all the way into the ground he's
making that choice because he didn't
want to burn alive
so like every time i'm sucking or
suffering or
frustrated if i have to go you know do
another mission that i'm of course i
want to do all these sexy things all
over the planet and but sometimes like i
don't get to get
i usually that's the way the military
works don't get to pick
and um i think about that guy and i
think about
the 3000 americans that were standing
there and be
faced with that choice of am i going to
burn alive
or am i going to jump to my death
because insurgents
wanting to you know radical fundamentals
wanted to
kn destroy the idea that we stood for
capitalism american freedom uh you know
with 500 000
and box cutters these untrained [ __ ]
were able to bring down the largest
superpower on the planet
like that's what asymmetrical warfare is
like asymmetrical is is something that's
not aligned with everything else
and warfare in these um
under asymmetrical warfare is kind of
the haves not fighting the haves and
doing it in ways that nobody's ever done
it before
it was it was genius and horrible that
this small group of untrained guys with
box cutters
did what's how many trillions of dollars
have we spent in this war
17 billion dollars in damage just in
that one day
3 000 american lives more life since
pearl harbor you're like we went to war
with the japanese and dropped two atomic
bombs
for that uh we're so
short with what we remember
this this current society's generation
this fast influx of information
like i'm i i want to never forget that
man's face
and do we know who he was yeah yeah
um yeah they think they're like ninety
percent
um there was another couple that did it
as well there
there was like uh a few dozen
yeah they got the black girl on the
right or or maybe she's white and
covered in soot
but she's literally looking down
trying to get a breath a fresh breath of
air
before she either suffocates or burns
alive
and then she jumps
like never again we say never forget you
know never again like how do we stop
that
and that is the constant
unrelenting fight against these fanatic
ideas
and it's not just there are countless
types
of of revolutionaries and insurgents
uh like ones that do it for religious
reasons ones to push out foreign powers
um one is because of the the the
um hutu and tootsie like that's just
ethnic
but they're all the same kind of formula
of we're not happy about something so
we're gonna do something
horrific to try and change asymmetrical
warfare to try to change
the shape of something and uh
that fight against this these extreme
outliers has to be one that we're
committed to
all the time otherwise that will happen
again
right it might be a train it might be a
bus you know it might be a dirty bomb
you know like thank god boston probably
the next
worst thing that's happened since then
which was a couple of
idiots with pressure cookers because we
have been so aggressive
not just here but also abroad ensuring
that this doesn't happen
it's weird right now you know i think
the last time i was here i was telling
you how bad it is in special operations
and special forces specifically in
recruiting like
we are hurting for people and the right
people
and all the people that have been coming
in they came in to fight this war but
now we have kids
in basic training that weren't alive
when 9 11 happened
i volunteered on 9 11 because of this
but now we have
i don't even know how many i'm calling
them kids they're heroes
that they're they're selflessly serving
their country
um but we're leaving iraq we're leaving
afghanistan
i i had a deployment next year that
looks like it's gonna get kinked
because trump is pulling back our forces
from these places
for us to do other things and those
other things are
counterinsurgency it's foreign internal
defense it's security forces assistance
it's joint combined exercises for
training and like while i want to go put
on my body armor and have a beard and go
look sexy and go do all these things
those are the important jobs that we
have to do in the coming in the coming
years
to make sure this doesn't happen again
right if we're in afghanistan
in 1999 with a presence trying to
help the afghani government have a
constitutional
republic or a government in in a way
would have this happened
maybe not i i don't know but probably
not
it's the same reason why we're all over
africa the same reason why
we still have presence in nato it's with
the same reason that we're
present in the philippines it's it's
trying to fight these radical ideas
so that security and stability provides
an area
for people to live freely however they
want to
we're not telling anybody how to live
right philippines
africa najir nigeria mortania burkina
faso you guys do your things
whatever that thing is we're here to
help you do it but
it's going to be done safely to provide
stability and security so
i never want to see that again like do
you want to see an american me like
i'm not going to see my kids but i want
to burn alive
so i'm going to jump
[ __ ] you and your extremist ideas i'm
going to find you and we're gonna fight
you till the day we die
but we have to be vigilant about it when
you hear people talk about defunding the
military
when you hear people talk about pulling
troops
out of other countries in a
non-interventionist foreign policy
but you know what you know and you know
why this stuff has to
be done how do you react to that
it's ignorance i mean at first it's pity
it's like i i feel bad for them
you know i'll go to a country in west
africa
and i'll go back two years later and i
will see
the school that i helped build or was
providing training for the people that
are going to be protecting it
and that school is still functioning and
they've had two
years of people graduating from that
school and now i go to what was like
this podunk village
and people are sitting there reading a
book like you can read
like yeah i learned how to read last
year what
this is so cool you know like you have
fresh water how did you have fresh water
like ah
well we learned um how to read and then
we started reading these books and
like we actually do natural filtration
through the soil
and and we're also doing this tiered
irrigation like check out our crops
like holy crap you have crops here you
didn't have crops here two years ago
like in in two yeah like in two years
i'm seeing this transformation of people
so
every single radical group from
isis al-qaeda taliban um farc
to antifa they
go and target the poor and the
uneducated
that's that's who they recruit from and
they they take these ideas
they plant seeds and they plant seeds
through um
like you're super poor your daughter is
going to get married i'm going to come
in
as the bad guy as the isis member and
i'm going to pay for your
daughter's wedding and um
and the endowment i'm gonna do it all
and now like you're indebted to me
and your wife and her new husband are
kind of like appreciative to me
but now i have a hook in you and i can
and it doesn't take a lot of money
to pay for a wedding in
somalia so that there's the population
there's the poverty and there's the
opportunity for them to
plant these seeds of fanatic
ridiculousness and that's that's what
they do so
when i see somebody that's like hey we
need to pull everybody back
yeah in in wars
iraq and afghanistan we we have created
stability there
and i don't know well we can never
govern
afghanistan like they can't be that's
just the way that the people are and
it's kind of cool and it's kind of
uh also frightening because they're so
nomadic yeah
i mean it's been tribal forever i mean
you go back to
genghis khan you know like they've been
insurgents
from khan to to the british to the
russians
to then the british again to the french
to then the russians again
then to us uh like they've just been
doing this thing for
as long as they've been in existence so
uh just leave them be right we can still
be there with the government
like hand in hand advise and insist and
accompany
like how to do things but we don't
physically need to be there fighting
wars all the time
um and that's kind of what we're doing
right we're phasing back our physical
direct action presence
but it's somebody's saying that we need
to pull everybody in we only need to
protect our own borders and let's just
be present here
it's super naive and it's super ignorant
because this is the result of us not
being
outside of our own borders the idea of
policing the world doesn't sit well with
people though
we don't have to please the idea the
world and that's not what we're doing
so security forces assistance or or
joint combined exercise for training or
for internal defense
that is i am not walking around being
like hey
you insurgent you get back in that
building um i'm
with like by with and through working
with the local government
by their side with them with their
mission and their intent
through their own purpose
and ideas i understand that but how do
you get that
message to people that do think that
it's policing the world
that do think that we should mine our
own business and take that ron paul
approach and
pull the troops back and take care of
our own and not worry about other
countries
i mean i wish i could take people with
me
to show them um have you ever listened
to ron paul talk about these yeah
yeah for sure uh
i think the the easy answer and i never
like easy answers
is that this hasn't hap 9 11 hasn't
happened again
even though they have we know that they
have tried
10 20 30 000 times they've tried
to do this again in every single way and
whether it's a
terrorist training camp where we got
them whether it's the new isis leader
whether it's the new al qaeda leader
whether it's the next
iranian um you know secret service
that's funding
groups and terrorist organizations all
over the planet uh we got him you know
like
we have been constant and vigilant in in
finding them
and stopping them and we have to
otherwise
like how is how has this not happened
again are there fewer extremists
no we have stopped them
through our actions if we did not do
anything
this would happen again how much of an
effect does it have
in who's president oh man a lot
like what was the difference between
obama and trump um
i'll just use ammo as an example it's a
soup like again not an easy
i'm just trying to draw you know
parallels
that people can wrap their heads around
um if i'm going to forecast how much
ammo
i need for training i'm going to find
out what my mission is
i'm going to set up kind of like the
training calendar of all the events that
we're going to do
flat ranges cqb long distance sniper
stuff
mounted training and then that forecasts
how much ammo i need and then i go and i
ask for that ammo
and um i would get like
i'd be allowed to ask for about a third
then during obama of what i was allowed
to ask
for with bush or now trump a third a
third
wow yeah was there a rationalization for
that
it's just like a funding um
like us being able to buy cool drones or
new guns or different optics
like the funding is there or the funding
is not there and
if um like while the big department
defense
military machine uh
may not be the most efficient thing when
it goes down to the individual
like it comes down to me being like i
can have this gun or i can't i can't
have this optic or i can't
i have to use this old rifle that's been
shot by
20 soldiers before me or i get a new one
and um and it's it's it's black and
white it's like
dollars and cents like i have nine
dollars
under this guy or i have three dollars
under this guy so when you
left fighting and went back into the
military
was one of the reasons you did that
because trump was in office and then
there was more funding
yes
i don't like losing at anything and
going into a fight that you are not
prepared
to win is a pretty bad idea
um and knowing
you like i'll use kelvin geslim as an
example supposed to fight rashad evans
at new year's eve um or at madison
square gardens
in november and fight fell through
medical things
and i i mean by the time i get to kelvin
geslum i've cut my
i've cut weight two different times now
my ballooned up to 220 back down to 185
220 now i'm cutting weight back to 185
again
and now a five month fight camp i'm like
walking out to the octagon
tired like i just warmed up in the back
with brandon
and greg and i'm like that's
really trained yeah but it's a bad
feeling to walk into a fight
not in a position to fight and we're
when when trump was elected we were 100
still at war
isis was thriving right all the places
that i went and fought
in afghanistan were now controlled by
isis
like do you know bad that sucks to look
at all the places where i remember
friends getting hurt or you know like
jocko the places that he went
those were occupied by isis physically
occupied and he lost countless friends
fallujah ramadi sauder city all of those
places all over the syrian border
controlled by isis land that we
controlled
and fought and then lost and then
thinking about like
i have to go back in here and do this
again but i have the third
a third amount of the resources to do it
that sucks
or knowing that okay now i'm gonna have
a guy that is gonna back me with the
pocketbook
to go and win and that that was the the
choice for me
was i just want to win
i don't want 911 to happen again and
that's hard to stop
when uh you're giving when you're
creating vacuums
for evil to fill and how much of an
impact has it have
has it had having trump as president and
making those decisions to fund the
military better in terms of success
overseas i mean we smashed isis in a
year
one year they rose for three and
and started gaining ground the isis
caliphate
into all of the middle east like they
were popping up we had ice people
swearing allegiance to isis and africa
you know like the boko haram was like
yeah we're isis now like what
are you kidding me and that cancerous
plague
spreading all over the world because we
weren't aggressively
with vigilance fighting those ideas
then um you know november roll around
and it was by at february
of 2017 it was like go
and it was off you know we're literally
smashing them at every single
opportunity dropping the biggest bomb
you know in taliban
the j damn or the was it the moab
yeah but that's pretty cool i just
dropped the you know
the bomb next to the size of the nuclear
weapon
that's that's awesome and this is all
because of trump
getting into office and funding the
military yeah so
the president comes out with this um
national strategic plan
and that goes to a bunch of different
things from department of defense to
department of state and every single one
of these
look to that idea that document as to
how they're going to operate and then
you have the appointees to those
positions
like mattis for example where then he
interprets
what the intent is from like the
executive plan
and then for department of defense how
are we going to fulfill that
and then that goes to all of the
regional commanders and
to all the special operations units and
then missions are built
off of fulfilling these ideas and those
ideas were
smash isis remove radical terrorists off
the planet
and provide security and stability with
all of our partners
and then grow who our partners are so
like in africa if you went back
five six years you would have
three or four five countries that were
part of this like this group of regional
africans wanting to be free
right like they don't want boko haram or
al qaeda or isis coming in and telling
them what to do they want a free
constitutional government so
we started helping now there's like a
dozen of those countries
that are part of this group and
they're all doing they're all doing the
work and
it's amazing it's amazing to see what
happens
in just a couple of years in any one of
these countries when they start
doing the work it's no different than a
person right it's like but it's a group
of people and they're all believing in
these ideas
of freedom of education of prosperity
and we're just creating an opportunity
for those to be realized
this is not a message that gets out
enough
what you're saying right now about the
importance of funding the military about
all the positive aspects of these
operations and about how
squashing these fundamentalist terrorist
groups
can lead to democracy and all these
places and can lead to flourishing
schools and growth of these individual
areas
yeah this is not a message that gets out
enough no i mean that's by design a
little bit
um i i think you know half
the country doesn't want the other half
to look good
um and we definitely know that our all
of our enemies foreign enemies
are 100 participating right now as we
move towards november
in delegitimizing what this country
stands for in the process
of our elections and what we're allowed
to do successfully overseas
so like you know from russia to china
like they are
in the business of hurting america
and they're not only here like making
our
election seem
uh unfair or broken um
but also abroad where they're they're
trying to
like every place that we are they are as
well and they are trying to do the
opposite of we
of what we like they want radicals they
want
broken they want um
because every little bit that they do is
more that we have to fight against
um when i said that an insurgency is
cheap and a counterinsurgency is
expensive but we're fighting count on
insurgency over the planet
um as we move towards the elections
with portland firing off seattle firing
off
like i think it'd be very naive for us
not to think that china and russia
are negatively participating if you look
at 2016
with hillary and trump um were the
russians involved
yeah yeah like for sure they're they're
stoking the fires of hate on both sides
and it didn't matter who won
like they didn't want trump to win they
didn't need hillary to win they just
need the process
to look broken they just have to make us
look bad it doesn't matter to them who
wins and coming to biden and trump
it doesn't matter who wins
it matters that they delegitimize the
process
of a fair election in a constitutional
republic
it's really easy to do
i'm gonna use all right you have a
birthday coming up you
are gonna turn 60. happy birthday you
look great for being 60 joe
and um you're going to have a party to
celebrate this
and um you're gonna have all your
friends over you know
you got some gay guys you got some black
guys you got some mexicans
you got you're a pretty balanced person
with lots of different friends from lots
of different cultures
not but they're all gonna be in the same
room right got this big huge melting pot
of your party cool it's gonna be a rad
party you got a bar
um you kind of rented this cool place
has you know some
few bathrooms has this nice nice balcony
uh this beautiful
statue um and there's like this ice
sculpture um that has some great drinks
on it and the punch is underneath it
i don't want you to have a good party
i'm i'm your insurgent i don't like you
i don't like your ideas i don't like
this idea of everybody being able to
co-mingle
so i'm gonna go and i'm gonna ruin your
party i had a friend of a friend that
kind of got me in
so how hard is it for me to ruin your
party
super easy right i could go piss in the
punch i could go find that gay guy
use some homophobic slurs i could find
that
muslim over in the corner and um you
know tell them that like the plo is the
dumbest group on the planet you know
that israel should own everything and
that you know muslims are
ignorant multi-wife [ __ ]
all of it's untrue it doesn't matter if
i believe it i'm just there
to piss people off i'm gonna go to those
two bathrooms
i'm gonna go give you an upper decker
i'm gonna go poop in the top of two of
those toilets well that's disgusting
right stinks
maybe i'm gonna go chip away at the that
little beautiful sculpture
so when somebody goes to scoop the their
first punch the whole thing
topples over so easy and so cheap
for me to ruin everything about your day
that's what they're trying to do with an
election right they're just trying to
erode
the process and ruin it and it costs
them nothing to go and piss off
every single group the far right the far
left they just want people angry
and the process is so simple now with
twitter and instagram and facebook
all right these set up these these
massive
bots that can go and like things and
create and they play this long game
where they just
start planting seeds of distrust and
and they are spending
money to make antifa mad they're
spending money
to make the boogaloo bros look mad
and they want everybody to be mad at
everybody moving into november
so then the process the election is
jacked
but your party so you do have an option
this is the catch-22 of how difficult it
is as a leader
to stop it like i could hire security
guards
i could put a guard at the front i could
have put a guard by the punch i could
put a guard
in every bathroom i could check all the
ids of everybody coming in
i could have like a exact list of people
that are allowed to attend
but now i just ruined you just ruined
your own party
because you're trying to provide
security and stability and you put all
of that in there
and but now your party sucks right like
i can't get a drink i'm only allowed one
drink
and nobody's allowed to talk to each
other and nobody's allowed to hang out
everybody has to be segregated and
separate
so you ruined your own party so in
either case you give me freedom of
movement
the american way and i'm going to ruin
it or you try to come in
too heavy-handed and then you look like
a dictator
you know you'll you'll look like hitler
himself
so how do how do you have a good party
it's hard
that's where we're at right now they're
literally doing that
with with every way they can
it's frightening so this idea that
russia just wants trump to win
it's horseshit yeah they don't care they
just need the process
to look bad so wait we we have a
constitutional republic
right what do they have
what a dictatorship absolutely so
they don't need a friend
they just need the process the idea of
america to look broken
that's what that's success to them if i
like
i can say this with such absolute like
conviction
because this is what we do this is what
we do
this is what we go overseas and do like
we have specific groups that are doing
this exact thing
to make them look bad but they're doing
it to us and
because america is so free it's so much
easier to do here
like how hard is it for me to go to
russia and
or land in china and go and start
planting
seeds of discontent it's pretty freaking
hard right
like here it's not
so hard to fight this so because of the
fact that we have freedom
and because of the fact that we have
these democratic elections because of
the fact that we have
uh the ability to express ourselves and
communicate freely online
which they don't really have in either
one of those countries i mean there's
severe repercussions for
criticizing the government in china
severe and same thing about
russia so because we have this freedom
over here
they participate yeah and the way they
participate is through the internet
research agency and i had a woman on uh
named
renee darestas who extensively
researched this and was talking about
how
spectacular this operation was and what
they would do
they literally organized a pro-texas
meetup across the street from a
pro-muslim meet-up and they set it up
they set it up that way yeah
yeah um a friend who's um uh uh
very well-versed online found this uh
antifa
uh rage uh this uh thing against white
rage
online and they they trace the ip back
to russia yeah and they're like this is
wild
this is wild [ __ ] like it's not wild
though it is like america
yeah america wake up your eyes because
wake up and open your eyes to this is
happening
where how naive is it for us not to
think that our enemies
are trying to negatively affect what is
happening here
right because this is the place where
you can negatively affect it in the way
that they can do it here
which is different than the way you
could affect anything in russia or china
because of the fact that we have this
freedom of expression yeah they don't
they don't need somebody to win they
just have to make
us look bad this is where our medias
failed us
because our media takes this horrible
partisan
position whether you're on the left or
the right they they only want to look at
the things
that show that the left or the right
depending on who your enemy is
is [ __ ] up and how china or russia
whoever
whoever you deem the player that's the
key player
is influencing our elections because
they want this person to win so if you
love america you will vote against trump
because
the russians want trump to win this is
this is the [ __ ] narrative that keeps
getting spit out at us
and it's not it doesn't sit well with me
and i'm glad you're explaining it the
way you're explaining it
because partisanship and this this abil
inability to look at things objectively
is
really [ __ ] us up yeah it's really
bad and these [ __ ] that are
running the media
there's a reason why people aren't
paying attention anymore
there's a reason there's a reason why
those those sources are not
trusted i mean divided is
perfectly divided like if if i if i were
in china or in moscow i was like
exactly what kind of environment do i
want
so i could negatively affect an election
you're looking at it right yeah i'm
gonna stoke the fires of the one percent
on the right i'm gonna stoke the fires
of the one percent on the left and i'm
just gonna
i want them so angry i've created all
these different accounts
that have thousands of followers they're
fake the followers are bots
and the people that are saying that
those are real people that speak perfect
english
and they are in there in those groups
just planting hate
so people just get madder and madder and
madder
you know we look at like black lives
matter i don't think there's a single
american
that that's gonna be like no black lives
don't matter well
there might be one but screw that racist
right so few and so
irrelevant it's such a minor position
yeah like
like the is there solidarity for sure
like are the solutions
the things being talked about not really
not really why is that like i'm spending
probably half of my waking hours right
now developing
a way to be able to train police
officers and get something into every
single police department
so they can like you know unconscious
bias
um training about how to de-escalate
understanding different cultures right
if i'm walking down the street and i see
a key seek and i'm like
oh is this a muslim i'm going to go here
and fight this guy the guy comes in a
little bit close because that's part of
their culture and it's also
part of their culture they have a knife
and um but i don't know any of this and
i just
misunderstood who this person is and his
religion and his ethnicity
and now i have this super bad
interaction because this guy stepped
into my space and all could that could
have been trained
out i could have taught somebody those
things
and with everybody being so stoked
on getting angry and finding out the
problems nobody's talking about
solutions
like how do we how do we if there's a
problem in law enforcement and
there is like how do we fix that can we
talk about that instead of
of trying to find the the next poor uber
driver that gets lost immediately
calling him a racist
or finding the next antifa guy that
um is really just poor
lost his job has been living in his
mom's basement and just needs something
to do
you know and let's give them something
to do and that's like make a positive
impact
that is a real part of what's going on
too yeah it's a real part of what's
going on is people don't feel like they
belong
and when there's a movement going on if
you jump on that you do you see
any of that guy who uh shot the uh
pro trump supporter in portland yeah and
you see the interview with him
afterwards yeah
the interview is classic you listen to
him interviewed he's a lost guy
a lost weird social outcast who found a
home
and then is soaking up all this
attention that he got for shooting a
trump supporter
that he's claiming was out there trying
to kill a friend of
his of color that was his description of
it and then please show up
yeah and he tries to shoot them yeah
he's just a lost person
yeah a violent lost person i mean
somebody with a lot with no purpose
right is a dangerous thing especially
one who doesn't understand
the consequences of their actions
and
my brother's a sheriff um nick
in uh in california and um
the things that he has to do in a day
you know the number of people and
interactions that he has to have
that he has had in his career and every
single time
um is it going to be this antifa guy
that just shot somebody
um in in monterey there there was
actually some antifa guys that had
thrown some pipe bombs
in oakland and then drove into um
northern monterey county and um set off
some more pipe bombs shot a couple more
cops
and this kind of got buried in the news
uh but my brother was one of the guys
that showed up there
and they have to deal with that like a
radical domestic terrorist
and they also have to show up when a
husband and wife are having a dispute
they have to walk up to every single car
as if that person is going to kill them
that person might be a dui that person
may not want to
if they have broken the law um not want
to get out of the car
are you going to make me out of the car
like it is the hardest job in the world
they're under trained they're
underfunded
and but they are the necessary security
for us to
prosper and be successful and my
brother's the most selfless
incredible person as most the guys and i
train with a ton of law enforcement
and nobody they're not perfect nobody is
no human is
um but you can you can't train
perfection but you can train
bad out of people and that's one of the
many reasons why i think training is so
paramount
and you know to the election and people
are always focusing on on the bad like
you gotta find solutions
if you're if you're mad and you believe
in black lives matter
what is your solution all right if
you're if you think that cops have a
problem
like i'm trying to find like i've found
a solution
right we're creating this this virtual
reality headset
that we're going to be able to put into
every single police department where
they'll be able to
listen to um and interact with different
ethnicities
that that are consistent with the
populations that they work in
the you know like be able to identify
unconscious bias
like i i'm pretty aware of the biases
that i have
because i look through the lens of my
life
through pretty jaded glasses right the
things that i've gone and done and seen
but there's no way that i'm aware of all
of them
but there are ways that you can train
that out of people and that you can show
them
and explore we have like some of the
best brightest minds phds
um law enforcement trainers that are
designing these things that we can
like put um specular theories my partner
in this
like we can take these things and send
every single lawn to law enforcement
department
and train people about how to interact
and when
you're a hammer and everything looks
like a nail and you're going to all of
these
different interactions with like is this
guy going to shoot me
it's hard because he might but he also
might just be having a bad
day and he didn't know how to
de-escalate that and
um but you also have to be able to
enforce the law
and that's the one of hardest things
right now and i know the chinese and the
russians are
loving the fact that we are questioning
do laws really matter can we just let
things go
can we just tear down statues can you
just walk out into the middle of an
interstate
and stop traffic because you believe
you have the right to do that no you you
can't do that
like the rule of law is there not just
for you but it's for us if you believe
in the collective
then you have to believe that those laws
are there for our good
and we have to make sure we elect good
guys that put in good laws
but like if you just don't believe that
it matters
and you can go and you can riot and you
can loot and it's just property
like you can burn that building down
it's just property lives are more
important than property but there are
people's lives that are attached to that
property
it might be how they make their money it
might be where they live
like watching antifa throw those molotov
cocktails while there were kids
sleeping upstairs in the apartment
building like shame on you
you're being played right now not only
that but what you said
earlier if you do destroy that property
understand the lives that are going to
be affected because that community is
going to be
entrenched in poverty for generations
yeah you're not doing good
you're harming stop harming
you know start doing good find
find like as we're on 9 11 the time
maybe the last time
that we were united as a country where
we're like
no never again like we can do that
now we really can i believe in the
american spirit
like they this petty
immature
hate that people have against other
people
like they're not other people they're
other americans
that believe in the same thing as you
and that want the same thing as you
they might have a different way of going
about it and getting there a per
and perspective but like we all bleed
bread
you know we all believe in the same
thing we all want the same thing
and just finding out how to get there i
wonder what can be done to decouple us
from the influence of social media
in terms of like there's no way you
could stop
as of right now there's no way you could
stop trolls there's no way you can stop
things like the internet research agency
in russia
or all these different online groups
that are just completely created just to
[ __ ] with people yeah
there's no way we could stop that now
nope
if we could we'd be better for it yes
we'd be better for it if we would figure
out what
is actually happening if we could
clearly identify the source of all these
different things and let people know
but people wouldn't even believe it
right now people are so jaded right now
if you said hey this is a russian troll
people like no it's not you just work
for trump yeah i know what's going on
here you're not gonna trick me
my my buddy shane and i were talking
about gaslighting this morning
and um he flew he and his buddies flew
their helicopters over the trump parade
that um just happened here in austin
like thousands of boats went out there
and um like a few boats sunk and they're
like
one guy rented a boat and he forgot to
put a plug in there and
um one of them was like a really crappy
fishing boat that shouldn't even been on
the water
and then one guy bought a brand new boat
didn't even know how to operate it and
poor guy stuck his boat
but shane's like flying around and he
sees everything you know and they're
they're robinson's 44
they're like doing these cool v flights
and um you know gaslighting is
telling somebody something that's not
true
they're seeing it with their eyes but
they're hearing that it's
not real right the original play
gaslight was this guy making his wife
be crazy he would he would adjust the he
would be able to adjust
the the wick on his gas light so it
would get darker in there and just
because is it darker in here
he's like no it's this what's wrong with
you are you crazy
wha what's so we're in a time where
people are telling us
what we're supposed to be seeing but
that's not what we're seeing
so i have this conflict am i supposed to
believe what what i'm seeing right here
but we're being gaslit by the
wrong information that's being curated
in our hands in our phones and on
and on our tvs so the lake travis thing
in reality there's hundreds of boats
thousands
thousands of boats that are supporting
trump three sunk
but the narrative you're hearing in the
media it was like this catastrophe
catastrophe i wasn't there i was working
but
like my best friend is flying around in
helicopters and he sees the whole entire
he has
videos of everybody um people are
crazy on boat sometimes but um you know
he literally sees the whole
entire lake from a bird's eye view and
he has photos
of the the boats the boats the few
that got were being towed in and he's
like man those were the crappiest
you know like i don't even know how
those things were on the water but there
was just people that wanted to
participate
and um but what is
this huge half the boat sunk there's 20
underwater
you know there's this this disaster of
an event shane's like
i saw thousands of boats with you know
titties being shown and
people dancing and trump flags and
am i being gaslit you know he's asking
this like
that this is the definition of it it's
amazing that the narrative was the three
failures
but if we take that as the micro and
blow that up to the macro of
that happens in absolutely everything
they're shooting here in austin
right we have what happened and then we
have what we're told
right on both sides you know like i
don't even i don't think you could take
the final version
of these two stories and be like this is
the same the same situation
like there's no possible way that
these two stories that went to the right
and went to the left that i'm now trying
to
cooperate could could it could have
happened in the same situation
like that's how far the lies or the
partial truths go
so how do you fix that i think the only
way to fix that is
some kind of technology that allows you
to accurately read
exactly what's going on that doesn't
exist right now
there there might be something on the
horizon that they're like
some neural link type deal where they're
working on
the ability to bypass this like
right now the connection between human
beings and information is you read it or
you see it
but you don't really know what it is you
know you're reading it you're seeing it
and you get confirmation you're not
reading it it's going from the person
that is getting it
to a thing and then that thing is
controlling what the next group sees
yes yes and that's a huge problem yes
like i don't want my information curated
i just want information right and let me
as a rationable
rational reasonable person be able to
figure out that is the
problem right the problem is you can't
trust whoever there's not
there's not an unbiased source there's
not an
unbiased uncan and every source is also
a corporation they're all connected to
the machine
in some really deep and and crazy way
the tentacles run deep ev whether it's
cnn or fox news or
o-n-o-a-n or whatever the [ __ ] it is
whatever news source
msnbc cbs abc nbc
they're all giant corporations they all
have
huge political investments and they're
going to give you
some some
super distorted version of what's
actually there no one's there's not one
person
who will sit down there's not there's no
walter cronkite no
on television there's a few that are
online you can get a bunch online and
that's one of the reasons why
online news journalism is flourishing
and so many people are turning
to these people that are online yeah
but they're also flawed because they're
they're human and they have their own
biases for sure yeah um
andy no i follow him on twitter
he's um he's been on the podcast he has
yeah pretty
pretty pretty uh passionate guy now i
guess
he was assaulted by antifa yeah hit him
with like some cement milkshake or
something
yeah um and maybe the worst mistake they
made because they ignited what was just
kind of an independent journalist
um now he's like nope i'm mad at tifa
you guys like beat me up you
damaged my brain and um you know but
his journalism on antifa albeit trying
to be as accurate as possible we know he
has bias because he doesn't like them
yeah because they hit him in the head
you know and they beat him and they
they threw cement milkshakes at him so
like even even somebody that
has um trying to do the right thing it's
imperfect because with that person comes
bias
like how do we just get information
yeah um again i really think that we're
so limited because the distribution
methods
that we have right now for getting out
information allow for biases
yeah you know and i don't i don't know
what the future has in store but i think
that we're going to come to a time
in the not so distant future where
you're going to be able to know exactly
what's real what's not real yeah
i hope so that's so cool yeah i think
there's gonna be a lot of resistance
against it too
we're gonna find out a lot of people are
full of [ __ ] yeah
how cool would that be if you know we
have the fact checker which is like the
biggest
[ __ ] ever as a politician's talking
it's like
fact check and the person fact checking
is the most
biased furthest thing from a objective
fact check that you could possibly get i
was like
but you're checking the facts what if as
that person
was talking real
time like this is true here's like just
the truth not wikipedia statistics not
like google also curated statistics
not like information driven from
whatever news corporation
but just like the real data was next to
that person
as they're doing the next debate if a
debate happens
that'd be cool i don't think it's gonna
happen you don't think it's gonna happen
no how can you have a debate
biden's not gonna do it i don't think he
can i don't think he can stand there for
that long
and and last i don't even know what his
ideas are
but that's the point of the debate right
is for me to learn about somebody's
platform well
you know at this point he's doing well
by not
talking that's not doing well it hurts
him
no i just i don't i don't imag i would
never allow him
if i was in the dnc i'd be like there's
no way you're debating
trump's going to destroy him but that
doesn't matter because the ideas are the
thing that we're voting on
but it doesn't matter because people
want to see who can hang
in a debate and they don't want to vote
for a loser
so if the guy gets up there and falls
apart in the debate and starts stumbling
his words
and starts flubbing and forgetting what
he was talking about like biden's done
on multiple occasions
a lot of people are not going to vote i
swear i thought they have a scheduled
debate in a couple of weeks it's not
going to happen
that's usually where i learn about
somebody oh yeah yeah
yeah they're not trying to learn they're
trying to win i don't know
about especially like i love it when
local politicians do debates because
those are like no hold barred
truth attacks you know like well i know
you took money from this auto park place
you know and like this guy's like well i
know you're getting money from you know
beto
o'rourke and you're like this is awesome
you know like
i'm learning so much right now that
there's no way i would have learned and
they do and uh
suck i mean we kind of have an idea
about trump's policies
yeah but how do we learn about biden's
policies
yeah i don't know i think they just i
think biden at this point just wants to
win
i think the best way they think to win
is to keep him from talking too much
if i really had a guess like the only
kamala harris is on doing a lot of
different interviews and talking what
are you laughing at there's i'm trying
to look up to see what the new
information about debates is and this is
the story
i found trump spurns traditional debate
prep with first
face off less than three days three
weeks away what is he saying we're
supposed to there's supposed to be one
in about three weeks but
right he's not held a uh single mock
debate and he doesn't need to
president trump has not held a single
mock debate sessions no plans to stage a
formal practice round as he readies for
his first face off with joe biden
in less than three weeks according to
multiple people familiar with the
discussions
the president has dismissed the typical
debate preparations he participated in
four years ago joking to aids and allies
that he's been preparing for debate
since he was born
this this is what happens to fighters
and they get their ass kicked
his ability to fight back an opponent in
real time
he's argued isn't something you have to
practice
that's yeah maybe instead trump has so
far chosen to prepare through
informal discussions with key allies and
with briefings from top officials in his
administration on various topics that
will likely come up
like that are likely to come up these
people said can you
would you do debate would i
yeah if if like another problem i have
with if i had to do a debate no no not
you debating somebody
um oh i'd prepare like a mother i know
you would you'd be fun to watch
but um you be
the control mechanism to the candidates
like biden trump debate with joe rogan
hosting
your questions i would want that first
of all i'd want no one else in the room
just the three of us cameras so we we
can record
with the tr yeah just the three of us
and you would have to stream it live so
no one can edit it
and i would want them in there for hours
and
ideas we get to hear what they actually
believe in what they're going to do
who they're going to appoint what judges
are going to be coming in what policies
from gun control to yes all of it
yes why can't we have that we should
have that this is 2020.
i mean we have the ability to have that
this is we're not talking about 1979.
we're talking about 2020. if they wanted
to do that they both wanted to come here
in austin sit down
and have a debate i would 100 do it my
god i would 100 do it amazing
it would be the best way to find out but
i don't think that biden can
handle i think biden is like i think
he's i mean people get mad at me for
saying this
i think there's something wrong and i
don't think there's something wrong
because i'm guessing
or because i'm pro-trump i've seen him
fall apart i think i've seen him still
he's talking he's had multiple brain
surgeries this is this is
him saying i sent you that thing
yesterday right
look at this this is something i mean
i'm not trying to be biased in any way
shape or form
i'm a bernie sanders supporter yeah i i
just want a man
yeah do a commander-in-chief i like
tulsi yeah give me a tulsi
jocko 100 that that'd be a fun
jocko run for president just the
beginning of it
just the beginning of it
he starts talking about his brain
surgery
the only uncharted person
totally uncharted portion of the
universe
is the brain you know i had uh
as we used to say in the center excuse
the point of personal privilege here
i i had two cranial aneurysms
and they literally had to take the top
of my head off i mean they take a saw
and they cut your head off and
and go in to find the artery that is
one was leaking the other that hadn't
before it burst
there's this those of your docs know
there's a every every procession
every profession has their sick jokes
the joke among
among docs is how do you know someone's
had an annual
cranial aneurysm on the autopsy table
only 20 percent of the people have it
even get to the table
well one of the fascinating things is
the second operation after the first one
which was a bleeding that gave me a
relatively low chance of surviving
i remember going down the dock asking
the dock and we you know you're counting
the ceiling tiles and you're heading
into the operating room
a lot of you been there and uh
i said doc what are my chances i had two
great neurosurgeons
and i'll never forget i will not mention
his name he's one of the leading
neurosurgeons in the in the world
um he said uh senator
for mortality or morbidity i'm thinking
now this is not a knock on this guy i'm
happy he's alive
but that this is what we're talking
about we're talking about someone who
these are legit issues this is not he's
gonna be sitting in a briefing room
when a bunch of people from the pentacon
walk in and say we have found the number
one terrorist on the planet
what do you want us to do and that guy
has to make a choice and this is by the
way when he was vice president this is
this is quite a while ago just this film
so like
okay the
keeping something the only thing that
comes from isolation
is a unibomber like there's nothing good
that you can take
a candidate and stick him in a basement
and hide him there
when he is gonna have to be in front of
seven billion people
and be their representative and both
foreign and domestic
about how we're going to be operating
and if
that that's that scares me it's weird
it's i know there's other people that
could run for president i just don't
understand why they chose him and why
they work so hard to make sure that he's
the guy
yeah it's uh it's weird that the
democrats chose that
do you think we're gonna have regardless
of who wins do you think we're gonna
have a fair election
i hope so i don't know i'm not informed
enough to make a
you know estate do you think here we are
in september we have
september october and then we have the
election yeah it's pretty quick
super quick november 3rd is around the
corner
i argue that right now people are trying
to negatively
affect our election for sure and
we kind of have to be aware of that
so the next time that you pick up your
phone and you're like do you wanna
i'm gonna fry this guy you know at white
privilege
twitter handle i'm gonna get you like
that
that person just wants you to do exactly
what you're doing which is be mad
there's a problem a high probability
that there's a lot of that going on
and that it's it's just feeding the
flames of hate yeah and it's even worse
because we've had this stupid
pandemic that has locked people into the
echo chamber of their own ideas and you
can also say it's worse by the way
trump behaves and the way he
communicates and this
this uh polarizing way that got him
famous you know you're fired and
[ __ ] you and get out of here and all
this this way that he's
become famous it doesn't suit someone to
be the commander in chief so all these
people that say that
he's not presidential he's not he
doesn't act like a statesman
they're right they are right this is not
what you would want
from a person who's the leader you'd
want someone who's exemplary you'd want
someone who's speaking in a way
that would make you proud like that is
an american president
yeah and the way the speaking part that
is what we got from barack obama what we
got
from him is so presidential amazingly
presidential as presidential as
anybody's ever been i would
argue more so than anybody ever yeah
even then clinton
clinton when he was at his best i think
he was really good i think obama was
better
but well-spoken articulated everything
yes measured you know it made you
feel good that a guy smarter than you is
the president
you don't feel like that with trump
you're like jesus christ don't say that
ah what the [ __ ] are you doing get out
of here it's like i'm not a
like i'm not a supporter of trump when
i'm see what i'm seeing though is
that if you're not if if you don't
ignore
all the things that are going on with
biden somehow or another you're a bad
person
and that that to me as a person is a
comedian as a person who hates
fundamentalism
as a person who hates rabid ideology
that's driving me crazy
because this [ __ ] is all right in front
of you you're watching him stumble
through his words
constantly left and right we're ignoring
the fact that he's 77 years old
we're ignoring all these signs that show
i'm
not saying that you should vote for
trump what i'm saying is how the [ __ ]
are the democrats running with this how
is this in 2020
this is what we're doing yeah this is
this is what we're doing
and even the choice of tulsi camera like
i mean or
of locking tulsi garrett out rather the
choice of uh eliminating her
the whole thing sat with me it's so it's
so gross the way they did it the way
they pushed her out the way they would
wouldn't even let her speak at the dnc
it's wrong
and you know and it was almost like that
she got canceled by her own party yeah
yeah it's exactly what it's like that's
that's evil right
like we have a smart veteran two
two terms or six terms rather six years
as a congresswoman
uh two two overseas tours two
been a congresswoman for six [ __ ]
years exemplary record
really reasonable really intelligent
displays all of
the things you would all the qualities
of leadership that you would want from
someone running for president but let's
doxer yeah
let's do that yeah boy the whole thing
was crazy the whole thing was crazy
and then and then his choice to chew
like he literally said
i'm going to choose a woman as a running
mate well how about choose the best
person
that best person happens to be a woman
that's great but if you tell me
you're going to specifically eliminate
males well you're you're thinking in
terms of identity politics
is this the same joe biden that's been
in politics for 50 [ __ ] years
all of a sudden you're you're an
ideologue who is going with identity
politics over
the best person for the job absolutely
clearly clearly
that's this is crazy talk kamala
so the parties diff on the police right
like that's
a a left progressive idea she is
literally the police she's a cop
and and not like if we're gonna
solidarity to black lives matter and
believe that we can positively affect
change
what she was doing as a cop she's the
worst of the cops
she was targeting in the most racist
vicious way
trying to attack black communities and
and black you know not even criminals
like
drug drug users and just hammered them
with everything she possibly could
and but now she's our vice president
president
not only that she withheld evidence that
would show that people were innocent
withheld it from defense attorneys she
kept people incarcerated to use them as
cheap labor to fight fire
when they were supposed to be released
yeah what do we have to do to get a
tulsi jocko
or a rock you you like the rock right i
love the rock yeah
he would be like a tulsi rock or like a
tulsa
thing they could literally win they
could literally win
and i would be 100 in support of that
it's just we're dealing with this
machine man and this machine wants to
stay in control and who is going to be a
good player for the machine
who's going to who's going to do the
right thing who's going to do the
bidding
i mean this is how they got bernie
sanders out both times
they weaseled them out and he still he
bends the knee to them
every time what i don't know why he's a
good guy i don't know doesn't want
conflict i don't know
yeah he's a very reasonable guy when i
had a ton of respect
for him um while i disagree with a lot
of his
positions in politics i i disagree with
a bunch of tolsies on on
um foreign policy about how to do that
but that would be a
conversation she and i could yes well i
would love to have you have that
because the way you explain it and from
your own
personal experience serving this is not
just
some fun i can pull it area fairy ideas
i i go everywhere with these things
um like i journal kind of like i take
little weird notes
um and you could go and they're all
dated from
trips to iraq to afghanistan to nazir
to nigeria to burkina faso to moretania
to
um morocco to south africa like every
freaking crazy place that i have to go
and you could look and then like
go forward two years three years and and
look again and be like what
look at this change like it's just black
and white written in front of you and my
impressions of physically being there at
the same place
removed by 24 months and that has
happened time and time again
well that's why i wanted to have you
want to talk about this because this is
a narrative that doesn't get discussed
because it's either you're pro-trump or
you're pro-biden and if you're
for trump you're a racist and if you're
fort briden you're a fool
like this it's like these narratives are
so goddamn stupid and they're so
damaging to us
and i think a lot of them have been
reinforced and
stoked the flames have been stoked by
people in other countries
that are that are acting as trolls i
think that's a lot of what's going on
there's a [ __ ] great video see if you
can find it the cat
what you got something else yeah yeah as
you guys were talking i found something
i didn't want to interrupt with but
support we were talking about uh as our
veins were popping
both joe and i russian chinese and
iranian hackers
all targeting 2020 election microsoft
says so they put out a blog today and
they detail what's been going on with
these companies but does this
surprise anyone okay so if they're doing
this
what else are they doing in real time so
they're not just online
if you don't think that there are um we
call them jedburgs if you don't think
that there are
foreign operatives that are working here
both at universities
and in cities part of the political
process or part of the antifa strategy
strategic organization
they are doing this in real time in
person
not just online this is craziest we
deserved
yeah strong strontium
operating from russia has attacked more
than 200 organizations including
political campaigns advocacy groups
parties and political consultants
zirconium operating in china has
attacked high profile individuals
associated with the election including
people associated with the
joe biden for president campaign and the
prominent leaders
in the international affairs community
phosphorus operating from iran
has continued to attack the personal
accounts of people associated with
donald j
trump for president campaign yeah
they're they're [ __ ] with us but look
yeah is it one side or the other
no they're all over the place trump
biden
the parties the consultants the the
point is they have to diligently
delegitimize the process and and the
only way
and the best way to do it is just to
make it look bad and to make us fight
and to make us argue
and like the fact that there's people
walking down the street being like i
hate cops
you guys are evil like do you know any
or did you just read
right what had you just been reading
what has been echoed like my friend matt
sun
who called the cops when the [ __ ] the
house was making noise
that's that's that's who these people
are hey the vid there's a video
of a crow [ __ ] with these two cats
it's one of my favorite videos there's a
crow and there's these two cats that are
looking at each other from opposing
rooftops and like wow
look at each other and the crow gets
over and gets near the cat and starts
[ __ ] with him the cat's like get out
of here watch this
so here's the cat and there's a crow and
the crow
flies over and starts [ __ ] with these
cats
and gets these cats to duke it out he's
he literally instigates this fight look
he flies over
like a [ __ ] bird is coming near a cat
why would he do that he's doing it
because he wants to [ __ ] with him so he
gets him a little agitated and then he
flies back
and gets him a little agitated just
[ __ ] with him just a little bit
and then he flies over to the other cat
and he goes back and forth
and [ __ ] with look at he goes behind
him and [ __ ] with him he's irritating
him
crows are [ __ ] smart man and this
little [ __ ] just starts
pestering these cats and gets these cats
look at him
he's pecking at his ass he's literally
looks and the cat's like [ __ ]
the cat reacts by jumping over and
[ __ ] attacking the other cat they go
off
and they fall off boom and the crow
follows him this [ __ ] crow is a
monster
that crow is all the online trolls yeah
these are biden and trump supporters
engaged in moral mortal combat here look
at the crowd
look they go down the [ __ ] hole where
the basement is and the crow's like rap
[ __ ] losers you're black you're white
fight isn't that amazing yeah that
video's about that's it right there i
[ __ ] loved that video because that
video is exactly what's going on right
now
they were just looking at each other
yeah the cats were just looking at each
other they probably would have
gone the rest of the day without
fighting yeah just that crap in some
milk chasing a mouse
you know
china and iran and every other country
that hates us and then those two nice
peaceful cats
fell off a roof fighting but that's what
we're doing
exactly we're like literally pushing
each other off clearly there's another
one
crow's doing constantly look at him look
at him just
walking up to that cat [ __ ] with him
they like watching fights look at him
he's like yeah
get after him guys get after it get top
get come on how funny is that that crows
like to do so awesome
they do it on purpose those little [ __ ]
it's kind of amazing
it is kind of amazing i mean i cut props
to the crow for figuring that out
but i guess crows are just like people
we all like watching fights yeah and
uh and looking at americans it's pretty
easy to know how to piss this off now
yes
like every single one of these little
hot button topics
pop up there's somebody over there like
oh i'm gonna push that button
then a new button pops up like oh i'm
gonna push that button how many buttons
can we have right now because we're
getting so pissed off at everything
yeah we're all button we're all button
yeah we're full of buttons
go outside go exercise go do something
go do
go have sex yeah please you know if you
want to make a change like don't throw a
molotov
cocktail go find a police officer and
talk to him for a little bit or go find
uh go to baltimore and talk to the black
community there and figure out how you
can help
you're like has anyone gone and figured
out how they can help one of these
communities
no because i don't care no that's that's
not that doesn't get you uh instagram
likes
the other thing that's going on too that
i i
the timing of the [ __ ] pandemic is so
crazily perfect
i'm not a conspiracy theorist in the
sense like i don't i don't believe in
nonsense like there's just too much
nonsense going on but god if i was
i would be looking at this i'm like this
is this is so perfectly organized
and then the response like keep people
from working
keep people from working so what so that
they're broke and scared and angry
and then they're even more subject to
this [ __ ] and now
as we're what five months removed we're
having that same conversation about
schools
well schools is a necessary component
for people to work
like if your kids aren't in school you
can't go to work because that's a form
of child care for a lot of households
yes and
we're like ah it's i'm not sure it's
safe man
you i was joking about injecting myself
with covet in my neck
like you could take my breast-fed babies
that eat elk and free-range chickens
and have lived in safety and security
their entire lives
and you could like cover the whole
entire room with kovid
and my 10 month old is gonna poop that
stuff out in like an hour
you know because they're healthy
balanced
powerful individuals my teenage
daughters like
we have not lived a day in this whole
entire pandemic
really recognizing what we're supposed
to be doing we have maintained health
outside
activities exercise hunting real food
um and like so
so better situated and prepared now for
what
looks like a scary six months in the
future i'm scared because
this entire country six billion people
have been locked up moving into an
election that is going to be a
frightening dangerous
election yeah so it's there's no winners
in this election
but it's whoever wins whoever wins is
going to be chaos so you the other side
when you say i'm not a conspiracy
theorist but here we are
with a pandemic that shut down our
economy for five months
um on an election year that looks like
it was
the origin is in china um
what are your theories i just think that
first of all the i talking to brett
weinstein about it who's a biologist
and he went into great if you you're
listening to this podcast
please go back and listen to the most
recent podcast i did with brett which is
like what four months ago
jamie three months ago maybe
something along those lines yeah maybe
maybe even two months ago
he detailed the the scientific reasons
why he believes this came from a lab and
there is a and and it's and he said
i do not know for certain but with with
reasonable speculation you could look at
this and say this makes a lot of sense
that was come from la
because of these particular reasons yeah
that lab was cited in 2018 for safety
violations
this is i mean china because because
it's a
communist country right because they're
a dictatorship
there's not a lot of incentive to
behave the way you would hope that uh
a an organization would behave yeah like
you're you're under the knife of
in the boot of the government all the
time that
people don't do the best work when
they're scared like that no
and that lab there's no incentive no
incentive
yeah yeah you no matter how much you
work
fear is your only incentive yeah you
don't get anything more for working
harder
or better right you just don't get
killed so
2018 they were cited for safety
violations this is exactly the same area
where they're doing
this work on coronaviruses from bats
and this is exactly where the or the
origin of the disease was it doesn't
take a rocket scientist to figure out
that it came from there
they don't think that it came on purpose
though they think it was just a
sloppy leak from the lab sometimes
things happen
where they're just perfectly aligned and
then people take advantage of those
opportunities
they take advantage of these situations
like there's a lot of people that
believe that 911 was an inside job
what i think is when they found when 9
happened i think there was many people
that took advantage of the chaos
and there was things that were passed
like the patriot act they were getting
fired up on that
sweet reference that constitution again
yeah it's
sweeping i talked to snowden recently
these sweeping just
overall surveillance of law-abiding
citizens that are doing nothing wrong
and they lied about it they lied about
it they all lied about it a lot about
the congress they lied about it to our
face
obama lied about it everybody lied about
it they knew what the [ __ ] they were
doing
they took advantage of the fact that
people were scared and they started just
just going into everybody's [ __ ] single
most
intrusive moment in american history in
our freedoms
not being encroached on not like a
little trickle of you know cut by a
thousand
or death by a thousand cuts like 9 11
happened
we lost and gave up so much
of our perceived um rights
right like no you can't look at my
emails like i thought my emails were
protected like my mail you can't open my
mail without a warrant there's a due
process to that
that's gone right like i think every
single
20 year old right now expects that every
text message that they send and every
facebook message dm instagram twitch
um every one of those things can be read
by somebody else that they don't own
that stuff
that's not how i grew up i grew up like
that was my ideas those are my words
those that's my property if somebody
wants it
they have to have a warrant to look at
it now
go from 911 to corona
now the second most serious time that we
lost
more of our freedoms 911 and this
winston churchill
said never waste a good crisis yes
and you want to know when a government
is going to overreach it's in crisis
yes and if you are not a strong healthy
individual that is able to be
self-sufficient
and be able to rationally look at things
without getting spun up by the echo
chamber that you're living in twitter
like you're going to allow that to
happen because you're just being
pitted against each other by this
dribble that's been
pushed into your face by people that are
just trying to profiteer
off of what you see and what you hear
and what you think that's exactly what i
think is happening right now
that's exactly what i think is happening
i think there's people that are taking
advantage of this crisis
so i think the way to fight that
is as a society to unify
to reasonably collectively be like
no you said they can't you know we they
canceled halloween
yeah they can't cancel halloween it's
[ __ ] crazy no they can't
the only way that they can is you
allowing it to happen
right they can't shut down your salon
they can't tell you you can't go
door-to-door and trick-or-treat right
they can't they cannot
they can't do that they can try and the
only way that they can't do it
is if you go and do it but the fact is
there's no uniformity
because they're allowing people to
protest so you're allowing people to
protest about some things
about some things because black lives
matter that's it yep allowed yeah you
you've got to counter covet protests
right you can't do that evidently
los angeles backtracks on coronavirus
trick-or-treat ban this halloween good
you [ __ ]
they should drown the fact that you even
considered it
dunk you all in toilets
yeah look at that we did we did it in an
hour we changed california well
everybody freaked out
i bet 30 000 people moved out of
california the day they ready
my wife got a text from one of her
friends she's like [ __ ] this i'm out of
here yeah and
she sent her the the news on california
banning
trick-or-treat that was her that was her
thing now pedophilia alone would be
another reason to leave
you know i got i'd be out of california
is there a lot of pedophilia in
california
uh yeah well here's another
legislation that's kind of being passed
to oh that what is that you put that on
your instagram is
it is that real yeah is that 100 legit
that's real so does that really mean
that a 20 year old can have sex with a
10 year old 10 years because it's a 10
year difference
so but isn't statutory rape anybody
who's under 18 yeah so
it no it's lessening the penalty for it
so
let's say a and uh the
the trans community um lgbq community
was in big support of this bill because
it's not fair for male to female um
so if let's say a 17 year old has sex
with a 15 year old
and she gets or i'm sorry a 19 year old
has sex with a 15 year old and she gets
pregnant
there is a law in place where
um the pen he is not going to go on the
sex registry
because he is a father to that child
would have a difficult time
being able to if he's on a sex registry
get a job pay for
child support so they have kind of
protections in place
where if that's only in california yeah
but
if he had um orally
or anally had sex with her then
the law would be the penalty would be
more severe severe he would be on the
um sex uh defender
federer list because he's not trying to
procreate
so the community like the lgbtq
community was like this is an unfair
law because um you know if it's a
a gay relationship they have a harsher
penalty than a
um male and female relationship so
they should be the same if while
i recognize that and i acknowledge that
that's the case
and i i want it to be fair but i also
don't want
a 19 or 24 year old having sex with a 15
year old
yeah no i don't care where it is no
that's crazy there's a reason 18
is 18. i mean there's it's a good number
it's not it should be later
how old do you think it should be well i
mean to have sex i guess 18 but like
um i was a disaster at 18. well i was
two but
i could vote at 18. but if i was 18 and
a 23 year old woman wanted to [ __ ] me i
don't think she should go to jail no i
was ready yeah
i mean 18 year olds are ready like the
problem is our perceptions of of sex i
mean i'm talking about someone who's a
grown adult yeah i feel like 18 is at
least pretty close to a
grown adult maybe you know voting we
should extend to 21 where drinking is
yeah it might not be the worst idea in
the world but as far as like being
responsible for your actions 18 is a
good number
yeah 18 is where and that was the point
of my post
is that that person can have consent
yes like the the way there's lin written
was somebody
willfully having anal oral sex right
um i'm saying anybody under 18 if you
can't
you're not willful you're not allowed to
be willful right because
you don't have the right to have consent
yet right you're too young too young
you're not an adult no yeah that's a
[ __ ] up law
and then we only get the crazy sex
trafficking of
i saw the picture of the guy who made
the bill too dressed with like a
[ __ ] dog collar on yeah he's a weirdo
don't make any laws especially around
sex yeah
it's but i just don't understand how it
passed
it did i mean
how the [ __ ] is it it just has to be
signed by newson it's so yeah past
legislation hasn't been
yeah it's it's passed yeah that's what i
was saying you just need a wet ink
signature
jesus christ that seems so insane that a
20 year old can [ __ ] a 10 year old yeah
like a 20 year old can have a 10 year
old boyfriend
and decide that it's consent a 20 year
old man can have a 10 year old boyfriend
and uh as long as it's within the
10-year boundary
so like again i realize unconscious bias
i have a pretty jaded view of things and
when it comes to like
children um you know heavily involved in
counter sex trafficking
um you know moving from deliver fund to
guardian group
um to now with victor marks uh you know
fighting
worldwide and and nationally like the
this disgusting thing that is pedophilia
like that is not a sexual orientation
and people in power like finding
children to victimize and they are worth
money
but there's a thing now where people are
trying to
portray it as a sexual inclination
as a sexual proclivity like there's a
tedx talk
about have you seen that this woman is
talking about
how we have to have compassion for
pedophilia the same way we have
compassion for homosexuals or trans
people
it's like what are you talking about
well i mean i have
compassion for the person but i'm not
gonna have compassion for any of their
actions
and if they need help um we can get them
help like put them in an institution
and they can realign whatever their
problems are but
also being attracted to a child yeah is
it is
period wrong end of story i don't care
what you think
agreed 100 but here's the thing how does
that woman know
like this is the thing about pedophilia
like someone who's not a pedophile to
say that this person is a pedophile
can't help themselves
how do you know like what do you what
are you basing this on are you basing
you're not basing it on your own
personal feelings like
i know i am attracted to women it's i
know it
because it's it's and i know there's a
lot of people like me right and so if i
talk to another guy
and he goes uh that girl's hog yeah she
is hot i get it
i see what you see but if if you're
talking about someone who's attracted to
children that's so
[ __ ] alien to me so if you're telling
me that someone can't help themselves
because this is a natural sexual
inclination like how do you know that
i don't i don't know that that's true
and i don't know what the [ __ ] you do to
save them
or to fix them i don't know but i think
the primary concern
is protecting children primary yeah more
than like
like having compassion for pedophiles
you know protection
we have to put action to that word what
does protection look like
that is law that is legislation that is
people that are being able to stand
not not allow evil to happen right right
for evil
to conquer it just takes good men doing
nothing standing back and being like
yeah i mean i guess they could recognize
and align themselves with being
attracted
no no no no not a chance the idea is you
do something
and you touch your child yeah let me
tell you how that's gonna end
yeah not good no yeah and it shouldn't
and that's how everybody feels
everybody who has children and
specifically
[ __ ] just the the fact that that
actually can get
all the way through to the governor's
office is bonkers yeah
and who knows what he's gonna do
which way the wind's blowing how how
progressive am i going to be here
you know i'm all i'm all about getting
reelected
and his chances of reelecting now are
[ __ ] slim to none
thank god they hate him now oh my god he
was the darling of california
beautiful man slick back hair looking
great speaks well
they [ __ ] hate him there now my
brother sis
my sister lives in um paso and her
husband
who i call my brother um because we've
been best friends for kid
since kids uh he works for a nuclear
power plant chad
and um so he's he's pretty like military
go-getter hard worker you know my sister
is a homeschooler she's
homeschooled all their kids and they're
brilliant like play multiple instruments
um like you know grades ahead of
everybody else and while the whole
entire world is like what are we gonna
do about education my sister's like
individual responsibility you could have
been doing it yourself not everybody has
that opportunity i understand
my my parents with being landowners my
brother being a police officer
like we have been in california for
you know that's where i grew up and we
have been fighting
for rational reasonable
politics and that in that and we we feel
like we're in a foreign land
yeah you know you ask how i came to
texas it's like
as a coward i just couldn't i said i
wanted to be in a fight that i
had a chance of winning yeah like maybe
now for the first time california has a
has a hope a chance of like changing the
course
of where they've been trajectory damage
has been done though
you can do you can undo it i love dan
crenshaw's
i mean if he said that if every law
that's written we have to
unwrite another law you know um it's a
hard thing to do
to take legislation that's already been
approved
and passed and then remove it that's a
harder thing than getting a new law
right
so now we have like this crazy amount of
laws both local
state federal and they just keep
stacking on top of each other
and they're not none of them are good or
most of them aren't i'd love dan
crenshaw there's that's another guy
should run for
president
did we just i just think california i
mean
there was an article that was written
about me being a coward from leaving
like yeah yeah totally you should stay
and fight like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] you for a bunch of
reasons we could start with you not
letting people go back to work
i think that's unconstitutional and
insane and i think that's so
short-sighted
and people are furious and then when you
see nancy pelosi go to a [ __ ] hair
salon without a mask you're like oh
i see how you people really are you can
also never
listen to anyone that is telling you to
lose a gun when they're protected by
private security a hundred percent you
saw that with the mayor of chicago
she's all for protest until they came to
her block yeah and she's like
get the protests off my block i have a
right to protect myself
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
that's what everybody's saying secret
yes you hypocrite it's just and this is
what happens when people get into power
this is my problem they're protected
entire positions
exactly surrounded by people with guns
exactly and they're telling other people
us you can't go to salons you can't you
can't get your hair done
you can't go and have a gun but i'm
going to sit here
in my high tower because i know what's
best for you i just i don't know what
the solution is i've thought this yeah
vote them out
yeah vote them out but even then i think
there's a problem with one person
running things
i mean i really think there's a problem
with a mayor or a governor i think there
should be a committee
i think this would be a group of people
but there there is right you have your
city council
so here in austin we have a dumb mayor
and that mayor has a bunch of city
council people that are also dumb
that are also dumb and do dumb things
like defund the police
yeah but thank god yeah 150.
150 yeah the governor stepped in and
said okay well if you do that
you don't get any property taxes that's
a genius he's brilliant yeah
it's a brilliant move by the governor
and if safety becomes so
uh such a concern here he will roll in
state police
to um
yeah the difference good thank you texas
dps
you're going to learn a little bit about
them they're amazing department of
public safety
for texas it's it's our state police
force they're
they're incredible they have this super
military academy
i think people when they hear military
like as i was talking about that virtual
reality
um training that we're gonna get to law
enforcement um they're like wait why is
a special forces guy
training law enforcement like they don't
need a police officer doesn't need to be
special forces
no you don't need a tank or an at4
or you know a 50 cal unless you're
fighting the cartels
but what you do need is the process
of the refiners fire and being able to
train
imperfections out of people like could
you imagine if a city council member
had to ride along with the police for a
month
that's a great idea they had to go on
the calls with them domestic disputes
pullovers for duis not sit in the car
they got to get out and walk up to that
car
they got to put their hand on the back
of the car
put their fingerprint on there because
if they die they want a little bit of
evidence
you know police officers do that every
time they walk up to a car if you watch
them
they go and they'll like put their thumb
or their hand on the back of the car so
their print is on the car
so if they get killed there later you
can find out who did it
that crazy how sad that is it is uh but
as that police officer is walking up
there hello sir you know you're going 85
and a 65. and i smell alcohol i have to
ask you to get out of the car we're
gonna do a sobriety check here on the
side of the road
which is dangerous um and uh over here
is the city council member that was just
recently elected
and um they're gonna be observing this
like how cool is that that would be a
good idea
it would eliminate a lot of people from
that [ __ ] job yeah
yeah they'd also not that understand
like you said how do we get this
information out like if you could do
anything
to you know like tulsi gabber and i are
going to debate about
foreign policy um i first have to
explain
and let them understand what i've seen
and that's a hard thing to do
unless somebody sees it and then it
changes you know
their view yeah
fun times man what do you think happens
in november
do you think first of all do you think
that
this whole voting by mail thing which is
uh
being hotly contested it's so odd i
get very nervous when one side's really
into it
and one side's really not into it i
don't like that that makes me real
nervous because i don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on
man everything that like if you pull my
wallet out i have a license um
from the faa like i had to send them a
whole bunch of stuff for me to able to
get into a helicopter right
i have my driver's license i have my
concealed carry permit i have my
security consulting license i have
my dod id like that's five different ids
that are like i can't go do anything in
any one of those fields without it
a little picture of my face and and i i
really like that
because like i can't access a government
computer without that card i can't
go in and sign my nc my um my annual
review my ncoer
without my card and it's like proof
of who i am and what i'm doing and the
thought that they're gonna mail out
tens of thousands if not millions of
ballots to
dead people to um
they don't even know who they're just
sending them to addresses did you see
what
kate what's her name kaylee mckenna and
me how do you say her name
the woman is the white house press
secretary she see if you can find this
she said that 117 of the people
that are uh registered to vote in
california
there's just find the quote because it's
kind of crazy
but she was talking about here's the
prop she was arguing for
against voter voting online or excuse me
voting by mail
she's like this is why like what is
happening here where there's 17 percent
more people
than are registered to vote that have
the opportunity to vote in california
they're they're um in 2016. i know i
butchered that i know but i mean
i've had other stuff ready to go for
this i've been paying attention to this
oh okay there's like no proof of voter
fraud by mail that
i've looked up and found that anybody
else has been looking up and finally
just saying that it's going to be a
problem without
providing evidence nobody's done it
though yeah no one's done it at this
scale
i mean no one's done it like they're
gonna do it what they're saying is
they're trying to do all the voting by
mail or a giant percentage of it by mail
that's never happened before
the same with the post office problem
they're like um
no we're not going to negatively affect
the election
we're going to try to do everything that
we can but like the post office is like
i don't know if we can do this right now
yeah when someone's saying there's no
evidence for voter fraud
in the past yeah right but what
percentage of people have voted by mail
in the past it's been reasonably small
find out that kennedy uh quote because
it's it's a kind of crazy thing
117 percent california registered
she she was explaining how there's
there's
multiple issues with this like these
people that are sending in these mail-in
ballots like
how many of these people how many of
these are legit how do you find out
how much how much research has to be
done how much investigation has to be
done to make sure that these are
legitimate do you see some of the
um districts in illinois during the 26
elect
2016 election there was like a hundred
and four percent
came in for yeah obama yeah like
that's not right it's impossible
it doesn't that doesn't make sense it's
like i'm 100 committed okay good
i'm a 110 percent committed that's this
is important you can't
be do you stop there you can't be 110 i
know you want a bigger number but
that's an american thing to want but um
so what i'm trying to look this up for
her all i'm finding
are reports saying that she's voted by
bill a lot of times yeah but that's not
what we're asking i i
know and i'm looking for the article
here so hard to find
i'm trying to like find the specific
thing have you ever started to type in
like a twitter
just write 117 vote
by mail i have okay when you
type in like on twitter for example like
if you put trump
in a hashtag the things that populate
underneath that oh my god
it's a c yeah it's it seems like trump
evil trump the white supremacist but
those are the ones that automatically
populate
yeah now are they um project veritas
did a funny thing um they were showing
where they knew things were trending
throughout the world
and here in the united states at a crazy
hundreds of thousands of retweets
through this hashtag but none of it
were we're going to automatically
populate in a search
under that same thing well there's a
real problem with that for sure the the
bias on social media is
unstoppable it's not just social media
it's information searches when you're
trying
like my my i love my daughter julia um
and if she was preparing i think she was
16 or 15.
she was preparing for like a debate and
she was
getting information and she's just like
googling the stuff and i was like
so you know in college i was we weren't
allowed to do that
and citing our sources like they had to
be like very specific and how that
process works
and um you know when you do real
research it's like well google's just
giving me the information i was like
no no google's just giving you the
information that google wants you to
have
she's like but i'm just google like she
could not compute that the information
that she was being given from a search
that it wasn't just a search right and
how do you create
how do you explain to somebody that the
information that they're reading isn't
all of the real information it's only a
portion it has to take it takes a long
time before you really digest that
youtube's another weird one where like
kind of uh
hot topic issues from an opposing idea
those get buried well how about all
these doctors that were against
this idea of the the pandemic
and the lockdown they were saying we
need we need herd immunity
like real doctors and i don't agree with
them i'm not saying that they're right
but i'm saying that like they were all
banned like some doctors are saying
we use hydro hydroxychloroquine and
z-packs
and i've had amazing success treating
patients banned
video banned the dangerous information
my own doctor
my own doctor said hydroxychloroquine is
fantastic if you catch it early
yeah he goes it really really stops the
propagation of the disease if you catch
it early but the
a lot of doctors but it becomes it
becomes political
brendan schaab when he got kovalev you
know what the doctor said to him he said
i don't know what your political
leanings are
but uh i really believe in
hydroxychloroquine he's like what the
[ __ ] are you saying
my political leanings how does it have
anything to do with my hair exactly give
me the [ __ ] that works i don't want to
get sick
he's like i got covered and so he got on
the hydroxychloric and he was good in
three days
like you got the the red pill and the
the blue pill yeah and they're both
crazy pills
can i just have what's in the middle you
know because that
that rational reasonable yeah give me a
purple pill yeah it's
this is a weird [ __ ] time for
everything you don't have to find that
jamie if you give up yeah i'm look i
mean
i found actually an article from two
years ago explaining
what how that number it was recently out
there i know this video
she's talking about it i found it in the
transcripts but i'm trying to say that
like
how they found out that there's a
hundred and twelve percent of the people
that are registered to vote there's an
explanation for it
okay people move and they don't fix it
like register right
okay so her um description of it is
she's making it seem like it's fraud
it's not fraud it's just people that are
voted
like it doesn't make sense does it no
that doesn't make sense and then she
just moves on so it's like it's not
that's fraud so she's playing a little
game yeah
that's what she just does yeah she's
pretty good at it there's a whole thing
going on today that trump
uh was being interviewed by bob woodward
for his book
yes and back in february he's down
playing there's downplaying is the word
that's going all over the internet he's
downplaying the
yeah divide the thing yeah she then
said he's not downplaying it when he's
on tape
saying i'm downplaying it and now he's
coming out saying
those words i used on tape are not the
words i said it's like
what didn't she she said there was a
also a thing where she was confronted by
a press person about that and she said
read the rest of his quote
the rest of his quote it wasn't just a
yes i'm doubt but because i don't want
people to be in a panic about this
but i am concerned like there was there
was an additional
quote i heard the quote i wasn't you
have to read it i heard
the vid like you can hear it oh let's
play it you got it it's not ours to play
oh yeah oh it's bob woodward's let's see
it like whoever's putting it out cnn bob
woodward but it's a isn't it the trumps
it's trump's words it's not mark taped
this is where we could get into like oh
okay i'll get it i get on the book right
now
right oh it's on the book bob woodbury
i'm just saying like it's all
how's that guys still alive it's all
confusing the watergate guy yeah must be
taking his vitamins
how long has he how long has he got left
how old's that
dude he must be old as [ __ ]
right yeah he's probably in his 40s back
back then yeah
there you go he's so he's biden no
that's the same age
crazy it is a different time though
people are living longer
you know um like i know some 77 year
olds that you're like
look shane uh my buddy his dad
uh is like has a six-pack he's pushing
70.
really like jacked he's out there um
barefooting
on the lake at like 40 miles an hour
he skis every single morning and wow um
all of his all his professional bull
rider friends you know like yeah they
got gnarled hands from strapping into
the bowls for so long
but they're still like chunky shoulders
strained necks you're like dude this
how old are you just look amazing you
know like i'm i'm 41. i'm looking at
these guys like
i'm gonna look like this when i get this
age yeah you can do that now
in the old days yeah dude
listen man i had him on the podcast
like 10 months ago and then i had him on
the podcast last week
and that's two totally different human
beings
yeah that's a science project right
there really there's a lot going on
but you can do that now oh yeah you
could do that now dude he looks [ __ ]
terrifying
well i mean still like ready to go how
old are you 53 okay so i'm 41 53
do you know anybody that looked at
hewitt um when you grew up
that was 53. no they were all dead right
they didn't they weren't jacked yeah so
like i remember
40 my my dad's 40th birthday and all his
48 year old friends were there and i had
to talk disparagingly about
my dad's friends but you know there were
beer bellies you know
and guys kind of hanging out talking war
stories of
uh you know their glory days and college
athletics
um now you look like my friends they're
all 40s
and you're like pretty fit jacked yeah
muscular healthy fast you know like the
kids want to go play ball and they're
like yeah
try to keep up boy well people know the
benefit of
exercise for overall health when you get
older now they didn't
nobody [ __ ] worked out in the 50s and
60s they barely worked they worked out
if they're doing a sport and once they
were doing the sport they didn't do [ __ ]
i'm gonna be a freak til i die
yes yeah that's yeah all the way to the
grave you're like [ __ ] yeah what is
wrong with this guy's energy why is he
training so much exactly
i'm still gonna have people come to
sheepdog response they're like this 70
year old just outshot me exactly yeah
when people talk to me about like uh
you know what what supplements are you
taking like all of them whatever works
what's working tell me what works i'll
get people on tell me what's worked i'll
take that
yeah what works what works no i'm i'm
just trying to stay jacked
i want to keep moving yeah i want high
libido
i want high energy i want a ton of fun
and
i want people to be like how do i keep
up rage rage against the dying of the
light
i'm not going softly [ __ ] one more time
into the fray we'll go yeah i don't
i don't think you people know what it's
like to be both
either people know what it's like to be
tired and weak or they know what it's
like to be strong
you know but when you've been both when
you really when you really know
where it can slide into and the only way
you know that is if you've been strong
and most people never really get there
but when you get strong and then maybe
you get a little bit sick or maybe get
injured and you go [ __ ] once this acl
heals up
i'm getting back after it i feel so good
yes
yes i wasn't joking
about the transformation um i i i
jamie you're coming one of these courses
jamie's gonna be shooting people
he's gonna be busy can you believe you
have a gun let's do it
you got one right there well i don't
know about the shooting people
he's ready yeah he's ready but like you
get this
this contagious itch yeah you know and
like you scratch the surface and then
you see what's on the other side
and you're like oh and then you scratch
a little bit more and you see like how
fun
and like food tastes better sex is more
you like work is easier yeah everything
just gets better
and then like you you then then you're
in yeah like now you're hooked
yeah and then but that process is is
like you know a callous
hand you know chunky ears yep
but man it's worth it it's all worth it
it's so good i just
[ __ ] preach it preach it preach it
from the rooftops but hey
get that hate out yeah get the hate out
yeah that does not help doesn't help
anything it doesn't help you either
solution oriented it's the only poison
that that
kills the vessel that's containing it
yeah i love that yeah it's
it's [ __ ] terrible for you and it
erodes everything
physically mentally um i posted a
picture
on instagram and it was it was off of
andy
no he just took all the mug shots of
everybody that had been arrested
they all look like [ __ ] it's so bad i
mean bad skin
sunken eyes weird hairlines like
multiple colors
you know like uh bad tattoos
every bad thing that you could see
visually about a person
was and a lot of people were like they
it looks like they have some mental
health issues
and i don't know how you see mental
health issues in people but
there is like a you don't let yourself
look like that unless there's a problem
do you see the video of the woman who
was saying i don't give a [ __ ] that a
fascist died tonight did you ever see
that video
from portland after the guy got shot and
killed i don't know spilling a pear
big fat sloppy lady with [ __ ]
sweatpants on and i'm like of course you
don't care you don't even care about
your own body you don't care about
yourself you don't care about your life
you found a microphone you got a
microphone now and you're yelling it out
because you've got a whole bunch of
other losers
who'd gather together and you could say
nonsense and they all cheer but i want
all of those people on this side yeah
like i i i feel sorry for her i pity her
i want to go take her by the hand
i want to walk a couple of blocks with
her i want to pick a couple of meals for
her
then i want to get up the next day and
walk four blocks with her and then pick
a few more meals with her
and then like everything starts getting
better the problem is she'd have to let
go
and realize that she's wrong she's like
over hate reflect over hate
let go of what she's done like let go
the path let go of what what you've done
with your body what you've done with
your brain
let go of the path that you've been on
and recognize you're a human being
and you can change learn and grow but
you got to recognize that this is
cheering for someone who got murdered in
the street you should be like this is
not what we're about this is all wrong
saying i don't give a [ __ ] of a fascist
die tonight like no
that that guy who you think is a fascist
is a human being he might have a child
he might have a wife
he might he definitely has a mom and a
dad like this is not right
no this is not how we're supposed to be
we're supposed to be a community
america is supposed to be a community
and if we disagree or we agree
we're supposed to work it out we're not
supposed to be shooting at each other in
the streets over [ __ ] nonsense
and you're not supposed to be cheering
about it with a bunch of other losers
that's not what this is supposed to be
about and no and no one is doing a
goddamn thing about it in portland
they're just letting it go that [ __ ]
mayor is an idiot
jesus christ is he bad i loved portland
it's amazing ten years ago i love
visiting there
i was there before the pandemic really i
did the moda center there
we do [ __ ] great though i love
greetings
[ __ ] yeah they got great everything they
got food trucks the people are cool
we run a course there uh a few times a
year
and we always loved like guys the
instructor is always like i want to do
the portland one
because like the the b and b's are cool
you got all the water everything's
gorgeous all the food's fantastic
and like oregon really the the whole
northwest
washington northern california and
oregon like they're cool people
you know they're like they're kind of
kind of hippie
but also kind of like about health
and about freedom but they're also made
a little progressive in some of their
social ideas but they want to be left
alone so
it's just a cool people yeah and uh it's
it's
a ton of fun but now we're like can we
run a course in portland
it's a small amount of people man it's a
small percentage of the millions of
people that live up there
yeah it's a small loud angry
[ __ ] up group of people where the
majority needs to
step up and they're kind of trying
they're trying yeah you know
there's a lot a lot of people that are
very upset about what's going on and
trying to figure out some way to
get the mayor to act or get the state
police to act or get someone to act
it's a [ __ ] more than 100 days of
protest i love the lawsuits
that are starting to pop up by business
owners yeah um what was that that
the district in seattle where they're
like oh yeah
chavs oh yeah um a bunch of people are
suing
the city and the state for not providing
the
services that they had by taxes
and legislation they're supposed to have
so their businesses were burnt
all because they're saying that the the
local government was complicit
in letting these things happen uh by not
protecting by not having police come and
say no you can't do this there's a law
that prohibits you from because a guy
has a cell phone
and you don't know who that guy is you
don't get to go beat him right like
i don't have control of this business so
i'm going to go smash the windows and
burn it down
all those things are happening within
that chas um
we're like well there's laws against
that right that's arson and that's
assaults and but you guys weren't
enforcing any of these
so the lawsuit is that these people are
complicit and it's like
it's gonna be uh one of them was a
father of a murdered kid
is suing the i think the city
the city of seattle for allowing that to
happen
well heavy stuff that's heavy yeah
there's rule of law for a reason
security stability there is
it's like you know this is a funny thing
that trump does or he tweets law and
order all the time
you like every few days law and order
all caps but he's right you need that
that's how you have safety that's how
you have peace
what's that uh the movie where you get
like a knight to go crazy and like the
purge oh yeah
yeah um that tell me that didn't inspire
a lot of these [ __ ]
it did for sure yeah yeah and
i mean you actually see like tactics
that were used in that movie
being used and sometimes hollywood is is
is more real than fiction um and
uh like that's what happened they took
what they were watching like oh
we can go and do this
you can't and don't try it in texas no
that's that's a terrible idea it's a bad
idea especially what you're saying about
all the
special ops guys that are here so many
yeah i enjoy the cigars
they had another dude um
yeah everybody loves you it's funny
thanks man i love them too
yeah listen dude we're all already
more than three hours in here holy crap
believe that how do you have how fast
did
time fly i don't know i was looking at
that skull and being like that that was
pretty
yeah it's a white-tailed deer shot in uh
idaho or
iowa rather my friend john dudley's
property
delicious if that guy ever comes around
can i just watch it yes shoot a bow i'll
have him talk to you i'll have him teach
you cameron he'd be happy too
yeah both those guys they'll be here cam
will be here next week if you want to
hang out with them
um we're we're shooting uh you're
invited
we're shooting uh thursday friday
saturday sunday
so well when dudley's here and he will
be here
um i will uh i will set it up okay have
you shot a bow before
yeah i i hold it okay you hunt with the
boat that's right okay cool
yeah i'll have him help you give you
some pointers and [ __ ] he's he'll
[ __ ] tighten the groups up like that
yeah he's awesome
that's so cool i appreciate you brother
thank you very much for being here yeah
i'm glad you're here i'm
i'm couldn't be happier you just gotta
start saying yes to some of those
invites
okay i will but i was weather's dropping
i was gonna be flying
i was just getting well we well we had
to put this [ __ ] place together
how to move in there was a lot going on
we i mean i literally decided to move
and
was moved in in a month that's insane
yeah so cool yeah
bought a house in less than a month yeah
i was like let's do it
let's go as soon as my wife and kids
were in i was like
let's [ __ ] go yeah and it all
coincided with the podcast moving to
spotify
which was crazy they thought it was
crazy like what are you doing
and i'm like it was a [ __ ] party
let's have some fun man
let's make it right we're going to texas
yeah all right thank you tim kennedy
appreciate you brother god bless you
goodbye everybody
[Music]
you